Oh my god!
Can you hear it okay?
That part sounds a little quiet even to me.
No.
Stop it.
No audio.
Stop!
I know you're lying.
What do you mean no sound?
Actually?
Wait, what?
Oh, you can't hear the game?
Wait, actually?
Now you can.
Really?
The game is actually silent.
So I'm just laughing to myself quietly.
Huh.
Oh.
I see why.
Okay.
Hold on.
Restart.
Redo, redo, redo, redo, redo.
Redo, redo.
Oh
Oh Go-shin-zama Ojo-sama
say the line say the line boss for old time's sake kept you
waiting huh oh my gosh oh my gosh you guys welcome welcome
welcome welcome to the twin snakes baby yeah
No, I was gonna say the most controversial Metal Gear game,
but actually, I don't think so.
I don't think it's the most controversial one.
But, you know, it is one that I think a lot of people are...
Well, not... I don't know.
I think more nowadays, it's more like...
What's the word?
It's more beloved by people than it used to be.
I think nowadays more people are like, This game kind of
owns, because of how crazy it gets, you know?
I think, so for those unaware, this is a quote-unquote
remake of Metal Gear Solid, first game.
Thank you guys for those silver chats!
Thank you!
Gaseous Snake.
I have a confession to make, I've never played Twin Snakes.
I'm a fake fan, so I'm looking forward to this.
Awesome!
Me too!
It's my first time actually playing it.
I have seen some of the cutscenes, but not all of them.
So, very much looking forward to playing it for realsies
now.
But it is a remake of Metal Gear Solid 1, so the first game.
But it is made in the Metal Gear Solid 2 engine.
And so it's going to look like all kind of fancy and new.
And it's...
It's different.
It is.
All right.
Thank you guys for the super chat.
Thank you.
Glad you're playing this.
I actually got into VTubers because of this game.
The VTuber had a siltry voice like sniper wolf.
But was replaced by a nerdy, energetic lady like E.E.
What?
What do you mean they were replaced?
The best explanation I've seen is that MGS1 is what really
happened, while Twin Snakes is what Snake tells people
happen.
You'll understand.
No, no, no.
That's not my favorite theory.
My favorite theory is that Metal Gear Solid...
Okay, so there's several theories, right?
First theory is what you just said.
That Snake is retelling the story.
The second theory is that this is Ryden's VR modding.
missions that he went through because you know in Metal Gear
Solid 2 you learn that he went through VR missions of Shadow
Moses to kind of learn how to be like Solid Snake.
The third theory and my favorite and my favorite is that
this is Otakon's retelling of Shadow Moses and that makes
the most
I think this, I think this is Otakon being like, oh my gosh,
and then Snake, he like jumped off the missiles and blew up
the Hinde.
It makes entirely more sense if you think of it as Otakon
being like, it's literally just like my Japanese animus.
Because he thinks Snake is like a superhero.
It's so great.
Otakon left in the part where he peed.
what's under special oh i do also want to say um this is my
first time ever playing on a game cube um i did have a
friend when i was when i was a um a little a little ghost
who um had a game cube and didn't let me play that kid was a
jerk um i still hold it against him i would i would sit
there like because he was one of my few friends that was in
my neighborhood and So, I would go to his house and he would
sit and play Animal Crossing and I would just watch for a
long time.
He was always just playing by himself.
Oh, yeah, friend in quotes.
Yeah, friend in quotes.
But I also just didn't have one growing up.
So, and then I don't know, I just never had an opportunity
to play one.
So, the controller, the controls are very new to me.
like as of as of as of like 30 minutes ago and I bought this
GameCube just to play the twin snakes but because I have it
now we can play more GameCube games yippee but I bought it
literally only for this game so um yep yep yep um so yeah um
What else?
Uh, yeah, so let's, what is under special, I'm curious.
Um, oh my gosh, wait, there's dog tags!
In this?
Just like in Metal Gear Solid 2?
The briefings are in full 3D?
Oh yes, yes, yes, we will be watching the briefings, don't
worry.
Because there's one part that I really love that Snake does.
There's photo album 2.
I don't know what this is.
It looks like a gun.
Previous operations.
Oh my gosh, Otakon's P!
Okay.
Let's do the briefings.
I think they're quite long, like the original briefings,
right?
I'm not sure to be honest, so...
It's been a long time, Snake.
He's got pants!
I should have known you were behind this, Colonel.
Let me know how the audio is, by the way.
Snake, straight to the point as always.
What do you want from me?
I just invited you here so we could have a talk.
A talk?
That's what you call sending armed soldiers out.
after me sorry if they were a little rough with you but
we've got a serious situation here only you can get us out
of it oh I'm retired from Foxhound you're not my commander
anymore and I don't have to take orders from you or anyone
else oh you will take these orders I know it you can change
move the cameras I can oh is there a way to zoom in excuse
me I don't want to like accidentally skip the cutscene ew
don't touch me who's this Dr. Naomi Hunter, the unit's chief
medic, an expert in gene therapy.
Are you military?
No, civilian.
Right stick?
I'm afraid of...
Yeah, I'm gonna...
Pleasure to meet you, Snake.
Nope.
Don't touch me!
Oh!
Ah!
Oh, God.
I found out how to zoom in.
What's the shot for?
What's wrong?
You don't like shots?
No, I do not.
Snake, listen up.
It doesn't go any closer.
Of all five hours ago, an island in Alaska's Fox Archipelago
called Shadow Moses Island was occupied by special ops
soldiers.
What soldiers?
What is she doing anyway?
Next generation special forces, led by members of Unit
Foxhound.
They've presented Washington with a single demand, and they
say that if it isn't met, they'll launch a nuclear weapon.
Take off your pants!
A nuclear weapon.
Also, how is he- I'm afraid so.
What hairstyle is he going to change?
He looks the same.
nuclear weapons disposal facility.
Foxhound, hijacking a nuclear weapon?
Five nights.
Now you understand how serious the situation is.
This is actually FNAF, you guys.
You have two objectives.
First, infiltrate the nuclear weapons disposal facility and
rescue the two hostages.
They are Darfur Chief Donald Anderson.
Oh my gosh, that's so cool!
And Kenneth Baker, President of Arms Tech.
Okay, I know those guys.
Those are some heavy duty hostages.
You're to investigate whether or not the terrorists have the
other camera.
Oh, let me try a trigger and stop them if they do oh Any
questions snake Questions I haven't even said whether I
accept this mission.
Oh my god, so cool.
Well, you can make up your mind after you hear more about
the situation Welcome back.
Thank you
Next one Oh, whoa Oh, here we go.
Oh my god, the music is so awesome.
We will know if this is really a retelling or if Snake's
dumpy is still as chonky as it is supposed to be.
I think it is going to be as chonky, right?
Next one.
Infiltration.
The insertion method.
So cool.
Wait, what if I do Z?
Okay, it doesn't.
The disposal facility includes a hardened underground base.
Even with our most advanced intelligence gathering
equipment, we can't tell what's happening inside.
Oh, Colonel!
Colonel!
Oh!
So, someone needs to penetrate, gather intelligence and
report back.
Yes.
No one!
What's the insertion method?
No one even bats an eye at it.
Sounds like a spy movie.
Not the hand.
The handgun.
The facility is equipped with sonar detection capabilities.
They'd be able to hear our engine or propeller noise.
Mm-hmm.
And then...
Oh, God, it's so goofy.
We'll launch a one-man SDV.
Launch.
as a torpedo only this has no propulsion device of its own
bond james bond dispose of it from there on you'll have to
swim you want me to swim in sub-zero alaskan water oh oh oh
that suit represents the latest advances sorry if i'm
switching around so much the nuclear weapons disposal
facility covers the whole island i'll instruct you by coach
I think his dumpy is there.
You guys?
Anyone going with me?
Look at that.
As always, this is a one man sneaking mission.
Weapons and equipment OSP.
Why are you even here?
This is a top secret black op.
Yeah, we get out of here.
He's cheeked up.
I'm embarrassed to look down.
I'm embarrassed to move the camera down.
We got our time.
That was my favorite part though of the briefings that I
know of where he goes.
Seems like a spy movie.
And he does his little handgun and nobody laughs at him or
nobody makes a comment or anything.
Just, everyone's just kind of like, snake.
And then he's like, what's the insertion method?
Oh, it's so funny.
What's the time limit?
Oh, geez.
So exasperated.
They say they'll launch after 24 hours.
This is so goofy.
Yeah.
Do they say what the target will be?
I love this game for different reasons than one, you know?
They did the countdown start.
Five hours ago.
Okay, so it's not 24 hours.
Gosh.
Are you okay, Snake?
Why does it just stop there?
Oh my gosh, so funny.
Wait, how do I go back?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't wait to see Unit Foxhound.
I can't wait to see what they look like in the...
Oh, I'm so excited.
Person in charge of the operation.
He's like, bro.
He's like, no, you can't be serious.
What is...
Oh, hey, hey, no smoking on the job.
Colonel, who are you speaking for?
She actually tried.
Naturally, I'm representing the U.S.
government.
She's still trying.
So he's in supervisory control of this operation.
The president of the United States.
Get him, get him, Naomi.
Oh.
So there's a lot of crap hitting fans in the White House
basement.
Now, at this point, there's still video conferencing.
with each other oh if that's a real nuclear warhead
shouldn't they issue a cog not yet the secretary of defense
has operational control come on is fully aware of the
situation just go in after you infiltrate if you determine
they possess nuclear launch capabilities a cog will be
issued red yo snake i suppose there isn't that much reason
to worry yet is the national security agency in on this the
power stats yeah the defense intelligence agency the dia get
him get him naomi get him bad feeling about this they'll be
sending us some support we don't need desk jockeys we need a
nuclear weapons specialist of course a nuclear weapons
specialist has already been assigned to us oh oh oh oh she
got him oh yeah yeah You get it!
You show him, girl!
That, you know what?
Respect.
She went for it.
She, girl, bust her way!
Let's see.
Support crew.
She's talking about Nastasha, right?
We need backup from a specialist.
Where is she?
Let her come in.
Enter the room.
That's why I've requested the assistance of a military
analyst Romanenko.
She'll be providing you backup by codec.
Oh, there she is.
Kinda.
Let me see.
Let me see her.
Come on, Snake.
She's built up an impressive record as an advisor for the
nuclear emergency search team.
Contact her if you have any questions.
She's also an expert on high tech weapons.
A female.
Where's she working from?
Her home in Los Angeles.
Oh, she's in...
California.
Ew.
Ew!
Ew, California, boo!
Roy Campbell.
Our guy coming out of retirement.
All of us coming out of retirement.
Colonel, you're retired.
Why are you involved in this?
Because there aren't many people who know Foxhound as well
as I do.
Wait, if I...
Is that the only reason?
Oh, yeah, baby.
I don't know anything else.
I guess even though I'm getting a little old, I still love
to be in the field.
Why are you...
Why are you standing like that?
Oh, my God.
Tell me the real reason.
Okay, Snake.
Sorry.
oh take it come on come on I'll be frank a person very dear
to me is being held hostage who is it what don't act
surprise Naomi Meryl don't act surprise Pikachu surprise
she's like whoa you have someone in there oh oh my actually
I I don't even know if she does know about Meryl being in
there, to be honest.
Actually, not sure.
This is so fun being able to move the camera around so much.
What was your niece doing there?
Several soldiers were reported missing the day of the
revolt.
My niece was one of those called in as an emergency
replacement.
Aww.
Oh, he's got a picture of her in his pocket.
She looks like you.
She's my little brother's girl.
And since then, I've been watching after her.
This is kind of messed up.
A personal motive, Colonel.
That's not very soldierly.
Oh.
I'm retired.
And I'm your friend.
Aw, well, if you weren't really my friends, you wouldn't
have pulled me out of retirement either.
Barland.
Stance.
Haven't you had enough of a moody bastard like me?
No.
That's the part of you I trust.
Stance Barland.
Please, Snake.
Save my niece, Meryl.
She's just here.
Awkwardly standing.
All right.
Okay.
I have two conditions.
Name them.
One.
He's got that.
He's got that golem posture.
Snake, you're.
Gamer posture ponies.
I'll only accept orders directly from you, Colonel.
No cutoff symbols.
Oh, my precious.
Snap.
That's why I was called.
But one thing...
What?
He's not Colonel anymore.
I'm not a Colonel anymore.
Okay, Colonel.
Just a retired old war horse.
Nah.
Naomi, what are you doing?
Why are you looking like that?
I understand, Colonel.
The way he scooted closer, so cute.
Why are they doing this together?
Ah, yes, we have 19 hours left until this nuclear warhead
explodes.
We're gonna, you know what?
Or until they launch the nuke.
Let's just kick back and relax on the bed a little bit, you
know?
It's fine.
They're so cute.
Oh my gosh, there's, there's, there's like, actual bros you
know it's so cute hanging out with the homies oh so cute i'm
naomi's third wheeling yeah just a little bit i'm invading
their privacy hold on is she part of this operation too like
naomi walked in on the wrong scene doesn't know what to do
she was in charge of foxhound's gene therapy she knows more
about those men than anyone else
She's used to seeing men naked.
Ah!
Don't sit like that!
Snake!
Snake, you...
You... Hey!
Snake!
Help,
please.
Wait, he's like, sat up like that when he's talking about
her being naked!
Oh my god!
Snake!
There are different types which will replenish the supply of
adrenaline, nutrition, and sugar in your bloodstream.
Now I don't have to worry about food.
I also put no that's snakes worst enemy or worst fear not
eating a class of drugs which will help improve your mental
functioning hmm it'll make me smarter huh anything else oh
my god the tension here it's a type of stimulant it'll keep
you now he's even looking away he's like now I'm third
wheeling that was quite a cocktail anything else in there
Those nano machines will also keep your codex batteries
charged up.
Poor Roy.
Oh.
I guess I can call you when I'm ready to go on a diet.
Stop!
Why are you doing this, Snake?
What?
The tummy rub.
The snake tummy rub.
Thank you so much for the donut.
I guess I could call you when I want to go on a diet.
Okay, last little bit.
Well, I say little bit, but it's quite a lot of bit.
That's okay.
Such a goofy old man.
He is.
The tension though.
Wow.
Okay, let's talk about the hostages.
Now we know the meaning of the twin snakes.
The chief of DARPA.
and the president of an arms manufacturing company.
What business did they have at a nuclear weapons disposal
facility?
Let's try this angle a little bit.
The truth is that secret exercises were being conducted at
the time the terrorist group attacked.
Look at...
Must be extremely important exercises if those two were
directly involved.
Were they testing some kind of new advanced weapon?
I'm not privy to that information.
do we know exactly where they're being held why is he
pointing his fingers um actually do we know where they're
being held i can't with the finger guts oh gosh sorry i know
i'm not paying attention but also at the same time i know
most of this already so it's fine it's more interesting to
look at the visuals you know
um actually do they really have the ability to launch a
nuclear missile they say they do they even gave us the
serial number of the warhead they plan to use draw me like
your french girl was the number confirmed i'm afraid so what
are you doing naomi at the very least they got their hands
on a real nuclear warhead isn't there some kind of Oh, wait,
no, no, no.
She's, like, massaging her calf.
Our arsenal is equipped with a POW, which uses a discrete
detonation code.
Gurley, what?
Pal.
Why did this is...
Wait, or she's pulling up her stocking?
I can't tell.
The safety control system goes into all nuclear weapon
systems.
What are you doing?
We can't rest easy.
We're right here.
Why not?
Oh, my God.
Because the DARPA chief knows the detonation code.
Yeah, she's pulling up her...
turn around snake do not turn around they have a nuclear
warhead it must have been removed from its missile all the
missiles on these disposal sites are supposed to be
dismantled it's not that easy to get your hands on an icbm
that used to be can't pay attention i'm just looking at
naomi press r1
also her her shoes are on the bed that's so gross don't do
that oh my god there's a in my room I think I'm gonna lose
it get out of here this is a clean mid cafe not a stinky mid
cafe where flies can fly around every every scene delivers
something new it's so it's like it's like a it's like a tree
you know everything is new how well armed are these
terrorists I know there was an exercise going on at the time
they revolted They're heavily armed, I'm afraid.
Heavily armed.
What about their battle experience?
The six in charge are plenty tough.
Why is she just standing man emoji there?
After all, they're foxhound people.
Hey, you're going to make me blush.
The others are next generation special forces.
They're not your average grunts either.
What was that?
That was like the most dramatic kick ever.
I can't!
Oh my gosh!
You're gonna make me blush.
We're just...
What is going on?
I cannot.
Can we watch it again?
Yeah, that one was short, so let's watch it again.
That one was so funny.
Oh my goodness.
Hold on.
I kind of want to watch it.
How long are these terrorists?
I know there was an exercise going on at the time they
revolted.
armed i'm afraid there we go what about their battle
experience wow you let the six in charge are plenty tough
i'm embarrassed what looking at him hey you're gonna make me
blush the others are next generation special forces they're
not your average grunts either thank you good luck have fun
on your metal gear observation my gosh the kick is so crazy
love it i'm such a fan should have done cabaret so what
exactly are they demanding a person's remains remains that's
right to be more accurate cell specimens which contain the
individual's genetic information Cell specialities.
Stop!
What are you doing?
The terrorists need them.
You see, these next generation special families...
I didn't expect to change the camera and see that.
Genes strengthened?
You've heard of the human genome project.
Oh, gosh.
They've been mapping the human genome, and they're nearly
finished.
Thank you for that.
Thank you so much.
The military has been working towards identifying those
genes, which are responsible for making...
making effective soldiers.
Dun, dun, dun.
There are genes that do that.
Uh-oh, Naomi over here like, hmm.
That's so weird.
They're able to transplant those genes into regular
soldiers.
That's so weird, right?
Gene therapy.
Yeah, gene therapy.
I'll explain this part.
Okay, here she comes.
Okay.
With gene therapy, it becomes easy to remove genes that
cause sickness and disease.
or, alternatively, to splice in additional genetic material.
Why are you so quiet?
You know what?
I knew that Naomi has...
We can overcome all sorts of genetic diseases and at the
same time, add genetic characteristics as desired.
I knew she had no British accent in this one, but I
completely forgot until just now.
You knew what genes were responsible for making the perfect
soldier.
You could implant them in the same way, right?
No wonder they made him wear pants this time.
Can you imagine?
on being able to isolate and identify those soldier genes.
The genes.
And in order to do that, it's helpful if you can study the
genetic information of one of the greatest soldiers ever.
They un-Britished her?
They did, yeah.
She loses her British accent for some reason.
I think for the most part, um...
Well, Liquid still has his accent.
Genes.
Mei Ling also no longer has her...
Oh yeah, she doesn't have her accent either.
Yeah.
Is that Jennifer Hale?
Yes, it is still Jennifer Hale.
It is still almost, almost all the original voice actors.
Just a few changes, like, um, uh, uh, what's his name?
Um, Gray, Gray Fox.
I'm trying to think of the voice actor's name.
Uh, George, George, George, um, I'm really sorry.
I've, uh, the ninja.
um what's what's his voice actor's name again
Greg Greg Eagles yes Greg Eagles yes yes yes George Sears I
know it started with a G it's so funny because I actually
watched a video this morning about um about uh the voice
actors of the grim adventures of Billy and Mandy and Greg
Eagles is also the voice of grim so it's really funny
because it's just like oh my gosh you are you are gray fox
and the darpa chief and grim like it's what yeah isn't that
so awesome isn't that so crazy oh yeah i totally forgot yeah
grim fox it's so it's so it's um it was cool seeing watching
the video and being like i i got to meet him I went to MGS
con last year and I got to meet him and he was selling like
some prints of the grim adventures of Billy and Mandy so I
was like I was like yo that was like one of my favorite
shows as a kid so because I loved Mandy
Hater took a pay cut so all the OG VAs would come back
respect I love David Hater he's so the greatest warrior of
the 20th century big boss big boss that's right we've been
working feverishly to identify the genes responsible for his
incredible combat skill oh so far we've discovered about 60
of the so-called soldier genes they have so much personality
when they move around you know i just love it so much so his
body was recovered after all yes and his cells have remained
frozen in a cryo chamber i thought he was naked for a second
oh my gosh information is a A priceless treasure to mankind.
Respectator.
No.
Priceless to the military, perhaps.
He's so awesome.
He's so good to his fans, too.
It's possible to restore his DNA profile from just a single
strand of his hair.
Oh, heck, it's like some kind of dinosaur theme park.
And you're going to put these genes into soldiers?
They already have.
You!
It's your fault!
By acquiring their skills through training and experience.
doing so we now know that hereditary factors are far more
crucial for creating superior soldiers i think he was
getting the dust off of his of his jacket we can't hand over
his body it's more strategically important than any weapon
of mass destruction checking the fly your zippers down
colonel the sons of big boss okay the sons of big boss
Dramatic stupid.
The sons of big boss.
Next generation special forces unit.
These guys don't mess with them.
They have an IQ of 180, everybody.
I'm telling you.
Don't mess with them.
Tell me about these next generation special forces.
Why do you look like you're about to jump him?
Oh my god.
made up of former members of biochem units technical escort
and the nuclear emergency search team their purpose was to
respond to threats involving next generation weapons of mass
destruction including nbc weapons until they were added that
is they who's they oh my god these guys didn't start out as
regular army looks like a pretty international group
mercenaries Look at them, look at them, their little
portraits.
And it gets worse.
So cute.
Most of them were from a merc agency that I think you're
familiar with.
They were part of Big Boss's private guard.
And after Big Boss went down, the military just bought out
all their contracts.
What was a one guy?
Oh, like the speedy fast man.
Outer heaven.
Outer heaven, baby!
After that, they were merged with our own V.
R unit force 21 and running men if you ask me these
so-called next generation special forces should be called
simulating soldiers they have no real battle experience I
really hope we get to see decoy octopus in this video game
generation huh video game they've all been strengthened with
gene therapy and they're smarter they carry genes which make
them excellent soldiers oh yes don't get careless just
because they don't have much experience okay I thought
international law banned the military use of genetic therapy
yes but those are just declarations not actual treaties the
interesting thing is that nearly every member of the unit
conspired in this attack what i think i like most about this
scene well until the static part is is the bit rate okay on
it on on youtube and like watching it like it doesn't mess
up does it Why do they keep talking about pants therapy?
Yeah, it looks fine.
Looks good.
Cool.
Looking clear.
Good, good, good.
Even though it's all, like, kind of funky looking, you know?
What the hell is that gift?
Thank you.
Craig Eagles is still the DARPA chief.
Yes.
Oh, Rob Paulson.
Oh, Yako.
Oh, okay.
It's going to be interesting to hear it then.
But if they were regular army, they must have been
interviewed periodically by army counselors.
According to their files, they all got straight A's on their
psychological tests.
They all seemed like fine, upstanding patriotic soldiers.
They're so patriotic.
But they all took part in the uprising?
No.
Several people didn't show up on the day of the exercise.
That's why there was a resupply of troops.
They cheated on their tests?
Was there any sign recently that something might be...
Also, I just realized?
For free?
Toes out?
Apparently they consulted classified information about the
soldier genes and performed their own gene therapy
experiments.
They can do that even that you do.
Oh my god!
Ah, don't get closer!
Stop!
Not the way he looks away again.
Oh my god.
Colonel, please put an end to this.
Colonel, I'm uncomfortable.
Even the existence of this G.O.
Marby.
Yeah, get away.
We had been hoping to investigate this thing quietly and
deal with it behind closed doors.
Shy boy.
He's a bit of a shy boy.
Be a soldier mentor.
Sorry, sorry.
Alright, last one.
Maybe.
Unless, I don't think they add another one.
They might.
They might add one about liquid, right?
I don't remember.
We'll see.
Unit Fox Island.
This is just how it goes starting a metal.
gear solid game the briefings are long special forces unit
foxhound your former unit and one that i was the commander
of an elite group combining firepower and expertise they're
every bit as good as when i was commanding them so they're
still around there are six members of foxhound involved in
really does have terrible back posture psycho mantis with
his powerful psychic abilities Wait, where's their pictures?
The beautiful and deadly sharpshooter.
Oh, he's like, wait, he's going through them.
Decoy Octopus, master of disguise.
Wait, I want to see them too!
Your oxygen!
Thank you.
Oh, is that it?
Hello?
Vulcan Raven, giant and shaman.
And revolver Ocelot.
Specialist in interrogation and a formidable gunfire.
dramatic pause sounds like a bunch of cartoon characters
maybe in charge of them was he doing something that was
off-screen I don't know liquid snake liquid snake yes liquid
snake and you're the only person who can stand where'd Naomi
go hello Naomi wait where is she Naomi okay There was one
for Liquid Snake.
I knew there would be.
She Liquid Snake.
Oh, she was behind Roy.
He's just that much of a unit.
Liquid Snake.
The man who shares your code name.
The solid versus the liquid.
Tell me what you know.
He fought in the Gulf War as a teenager.
The youngest person in the SAS.
In the SAS.
He is pretty sassy.
destroy mobile scud missile launching platforms you were
there too i believe didn't you infiltrate western iraq with
a platoon of green berets i was just a kid myself back then
oh the details are classified but it seems that originally
he penetrated the middle how do you feel about that how do
you feel about that he's a spy for the british secret
intelligence service but he never once showed his face in
Century House.
He was taken prisoner in Iraq.
Yeah, Asylvania.
You like Asylvania, don't you?
After you retired, he was rescued and became a member of
Foxhound.
I thought that by the time I left, they were no longer using
codenames.
I don't know his real name.
That information is so highly classified that even I can't
look at it.
Ooh, I know it.
Let me see.
Oh my gosh, wait, you can actually see it!
You can actually tell that it's him!
Pretty shocking.
His skin tone is different.
Otherwise, you two are exact duplicates.
I have a twin.
I don't know the details, but it seems so.
I have a twin?
That's why we really need you for this mission.
You're the only one who can beat him.
Big boss was kind of freaky out there.
You've got something that he doesn't.
Why don't I find that thought more comforting?
Why is he standing like that?
Why was he standing like that?
Like the Hulk.
Alright guys.
How are we feeling?
We getting a good vibe of the...
of the game so far?
Isn't it?
Getting a good vibe of...
What we're in for!
Oh, wait, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no!
Thank you!
Really digging the MGS telenovela.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, yeah, oh, the haircut.
Wait, did I just accidentally skip something?
Maybe that was the part where he cuts his hair.
Oh, no!
I thought I had accidentally...
I thought I had accidentally clicked on...
the file zero again.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe if I leave again, it will do it, right?
Let's see.
No, I missed it!
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I'm sorry.
Haven't seen this title screen in so long.
If I wait on this screen, I don't think it shows the video,
but that's okay.
I think we still see it when we do new game anyway so we
press on you have to select exit that's what i did i pressed
exit watch the last brief okay let's try that one more sorry
i do want to see it i'm sorry i thought i accidentally
pressed zero again let's try it liquid snakes wasn't that
long right just audio again i think don't worry oh is it
let's just try it though It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
No worries.
No rush.
Liquid snake.
My controller cord is like everywhere.
The solid versus the liquid.
Tell me what you know.
He fought in the Gulf War as a teenager.
The youngest person in the SAS.
His job was to track down and destroy mobile scud missile
launching platforms.
Oh my gosh, the almost convenient censoring of...
What if they, like, censored...
Like, what if Snake really was...
Snakey, and, like, they just censored him in, like, crazy
ways.
Kind of like how in MGS2 with Raiden, when he's on the
torture device, they censor him with, like, the straw from
the soda can.
Like, an Austin Power...
Yes, yes, yes!
I've never seen Austin Power's.
after that there was no trace of him for several years after
you retired i've never seen austin powers and became a
member of foxhound i thought that by the time i left they
were no longer using codenames i don't know his real name my
um my mom never let me she said it was too inappropriate
even i can't look at it she was like you're not allowed to
you're not allowed to um oh my gosh You could see him there.
You could see him.
But, yeah.
Makes sense.
Yeah, she was like, you're not allowed to watch.
But otherwise, you two are exact duplicates.
The gasp.
I have a twin.
I don't know the details, but it seems so.
He doesn't look like he gets a haircut.
He looks...
Unless, like...
He looks more like how he does in...
In two maybe.
Now that I've met you, I know.
Maybe he's got like a little bit of a longer hair?
Like, it doesn't look like he cuts it that much.
The stance.
Okay.
Okay, now exit.
it's okay it's okay we missed out but all he does is cut his
hair okay new game normal hard very easy easy I got I'm
gonna try on normal because I feel like um rip run uh um but
again this is my first time a GameCube controller so I'm
gonna do my bestest.
You're a pro?
Oh, absolutely.
Oh, I am a pro.
Absolutely.
Mint, boss, big, big moss.
Thank you for the pink.
Thank you so much.
Let's go.
Uh, radar for novices.
Standard.
There we go.
Game start.
Yes.
Woo.
Here we go.
David Hader.
Yeah.
Christopher Randolph.
Yeah!
Debbie Mae West?
Paul Eiding?
Yeah!
Jennifer Hill?
Kimmy?
Yes!
Yeah!
Whoa!
Rob Wilson?
Yeah!
Patrick Zimmerman?
Doug Stone?
The voice of Ocelot is the husband of Chris Zimmerman, who
she is the one who like directed all the voices and
everything.
Like she's so awesome.
Awesome.
Her direction for the games is just so cool.
But they were like, who do we get to voice Ocelot?
And they...
Look at the rats.
They just kind of like chose him.
And he was so perfect.
Oh!
He'll be through here.
Wow!
I'm going to swap down a couple of bothersome flies.
There he goes.
Liquid.
Bulletin some flies.
Cam Clark!
Yes!
He's so him.
I know.
It's so great.
Ooh, the sounds are, like, kind of nice.
Look at us.
Wait, where'd our flippers go?
I guess we just dug.
Nobody sees me.
Sneaky, sneaky.
Nobody sees.
It's good to have you back, boss.
Thank you.
Thanks for the super chat.
This is Snake.
Colonel, can you hear me?
Loud and clear.
What's the situation, Snake?
Looks like the elevator in the back is the only way up.
Just as I expected.
You'll have to take the elevator to the surface.
sees you yep if you need to contact me by codec the
frequency is 140.85 140.8 push the pause button and then the
a button what when we need to contact you the codec will
beep when you hear that noise press the pause button and
then the a button to receive the call oh the codec's
receiver directly stimulates the small bones of your ear no
one but you will be able to hear it My small bones!
Okay, I'm ready to go.
I guess it makes sense because there is no select on the
controller.
Oh, how?
Hello, Colonel.
Snake, you'll have to crawl to get through there.
First, crouch down by pressing the crawl button.
What does that mean?
And then press the control stick in the direction you want
to crawl.
Okay.
Oh!
Just remember that you can't move very fast when you're
crawling.
Okay.
You can stand up by pressing the crawl button again.
Thank you.
Start plus A button.
Is there still the ration down here, or?
Oh, yes, there is.
I'll take that.
Stomp, stomp, stomp, stomp, stomp, stomp, stomp.
Nice.
Uh, get up there.
Get up.
Okay, nice.
Okay, so why is basically triangle the action button?
Good to know.
And then crawl.
Okay.
That's B.
A is nothing.
Oh, X.
Okay.
And then, uh, look at the rat!
Look at the rat!
Look at him go!
He's so fat!
Uh, okay.
Okay.
My cigarettes, my sculpt.
Okay, my ration.
Okay.
Oh!
Okay, this is first person view.
Okay.
Oh, don't, oh shit.
No, no one.
No one.
Ah!
Why is your vision so good already?
Um.
Hey, hold on though.
they're stupid they don't know they can't get over here
um i'm trying to figure out the controls can you leave me
alone for like two seconds the ration the other rations over
there then there should be another rack
no don't die in security
one 80 iq by the way um i mean He saw me.
That was pretty good.
The way he saw me.
It's not bad.
It's not bad, right?
Okay.
From...
I have to get used to X as the crawl button.
That's so weird.
It's...
It's new.
It's strange.
But it's okay.
We're gonna...
We're gonna fumble a little bit.
Oh my gosh.
I just pressed the wrong button again.
This is fine.
We're gonna fumble.
Ah!
Wait, I think he saw me at the same time.
No!
Oh my god!
I was in a cutscene!
This is so unfair!
They won't come over here.
They also won't see me from here.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, how the water going down the thing is so cool.
Like, he's just gonna leave.
This is so messed up, you guys.
This is messed up.
Oh, please just go away so I can start the game.
Um, I think, um...
What was it?
Uh, there...
Okay, so this is crawl.
Okay.
Don't see me, you bastard.
Don't see me.
I need to go get the gun.
Where's the rest of the guys, though?
Hold on.
Okay, this way.
Alright, go, Snake go.
Okay.
We're not gonna let them see us.
I got distracted by the rat at first, okay?
But not this time.
We're gonna flip this guy.
We're gonna flip him over.
I think it's A.
Oh.
everybody nothing weird going on here thank you okay
turn around
oh grab them grab them oh god no grab them no what's going
on no okay we're fine
yoink he didn't see anything he didn't see anything
Oh my god, he's so short.
I would have never seen you, pipsqueak.
I would have never even noticed you were there.
It was not accidental.
For the M9.
Okay, I think I can go.
You know what?
Alright, let's go, Snake.
Ah!
It's the enemy.
I need help.
Uh, uh, open...
Start the...
Start the elevator.
Uh, you guys, this is not good.
Um, okay, this is our first time.
How do I shoot?
Wait, okay, hold on.
How do I use the gun?
Uh-oh.
Oh, gosh, I'm fighting with my hands.
Wait, hold on, I can't...
Stop it!
I don't know how to shoot!
This is unfair!
Wait, press A button to aim!
A!
Oh, I unequipped it.
We're fine, everybody.
Oh, no.
what the hell was that um oh my god i don't know how to use
these controllers
caught the dodge roll i know it was so okay all right this
is this is fine this is so fine you guys this is fine do i
still have my nope let's go oh i don't want that go away
okay this is fine
that.
Stomp, stomp, stomp.
Yes, yes, yes.
It's just a little bit of, uh, a little bit of, uh,
performance anxiety.
But we're fine.
I wish I had my gun.
Don't, don't see me here.
Turn around and walk away.
Don't get distracted by the rat.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Don't get distracted by the rat.
Where is he anyway?
I think that guy's going to walk over here.
I do want to get the other ration in the other corner.
We can probably forego the one that was...
What's the word?
The one in the lower corner.
He's going to come back here.
He's going to pass us, I think.
don't know their route at all.
Oh, here he is.
Look at you.
Teeny tiny little baby.
What is that?
What does that sound?
It's like a scuttles.
Oh,
there it is.
And then there's another guy on there.
Yup, yup, yup, yup.
So I, wait, don't, do I need to press a button while I'm in
there?
It must be why then, right?
To press the button or I guess.
Snake made win.
Oh.
Okay.
So it's A.
Doki.
Waku.
Maybe not Waku.
I don't know where this guy goes.
Okay.
I want to be able to shoot him.
So once this guy comes back through here, I got him.
Okay.
So it's A.
A and Z.
Right.
Wait, okay.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
It must be, why, right?
It's triangle.
Oh, hey!
Get out of here!
Lazy bones!
Come on, get out of here!
I don't know what their pattern is.
Okay, it's why to get out of here.
We don't want to get out just yet.
Are they gonna see me?
Don't see me, okay?
Oh!
wait this one no I was right okay a oh gosh can you peek
around the corner again oh my god no oh gosh dang it stop it
stop stop shooting me I can't with this oh I got him look oh
my god stop shooting me I'm trying to learn the controls
I've never played on this tank thing holding the gun.
Oh, I unequiped.
Wait.
I didn't unequip it.
What happened?
Missed.
Uh.
Why are you just shooting?
Ah!
Okay, he's gone.
Uh, maybe I can get him from over here.
Oh, dang it, you jerk.
Hey.
Hey, you.
Oh.
Can I?
Uh, it's B.
right there we go okay all right don't oh my god ah oh
please shoot please shoot
can i loot these oh it's fine
of course getting out of the dang locker okay it's fine
though we got this you guys this game this game i just got
to get used to it a little bit oh what is going on Oh, oh,
whoa, whoa!
There, there's the Hynde!
Liquid!
Yo!
Oh my god!
Whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh my god!
Yo, that was so crazy!
also for anyone in quote curious i'm not necessarily going
for a full non-lethal um route because i feel in this game
it doesn't make much sense i will maybe for the guards there
might be sometimes i kill guards but for the bosses i'm
going to kill them because it only makes sense they end up
dying anyway so i gotta kill him ultra violence you enjoy
all the killing it's snake i'm in front of the disposal
facility i took a long time sorry i guess you're feeling a
little rusty don't worry it's been a while but it's all
coming back to me sorry colonel how's that age hasn't slowed
you down one bit yeah not the call outline I'm grateful if
it weren't for your suit and your shot I would have turned
into a popsicle out there Took you a long time All of the
genome soldiers in this exercise are using it.
I see I'm relieved to hear that already Sorry, Colonel.
I had coffee and it's making me shake a little by the way.
How's the diversionary operation going?
Two F-16s just took off from Galena and are headed your way.
The terrorist radar should have already picked them up Tew
Behind D?
What's the Russian gunship doing here?
Oh no, I'm gonna have to fight that later.
Actually, I'm curious how the propelling part will be.
Oh.
Who's that?
Oh!
I was looking at the guy behind him.
Look what is in there.
Oh, I see.
Whoa.
My controller's rumbly.
Now's your best chance to slip in unnoticed.
Unnoticed.
Snake.
Unnoticed, Snake.
There are only 18 hours left until their deadline.
You've got to hurry.
Well, whose fault is that for not getting...
You must be crazy to fly hind in this kind of weather.
who's that oh my god she sounds so different i haven't
introduced you to yet this is mayling mayling she was
assigned to us as our visual and data processing specialist
she designed your codec as well as your soliton radar system
contact her like it sounds the same but different you know
nice to meet you sneak it's an honor to speak to a living
legend like yourself oh it doesn't sound so bad actually
it's not oh it's wrong nothing i just didn't expect a
world-class of military technology to be so so cute you're
just flattering me no i'm serious well i know i won't be
bored for the next 18 hours what's this i'm being hit on by
the famous solid snake but i'm surprised i i didn't think
you'd be so frank looks like no my name is snake it does
doesn't it Well, let's get to know each other better.
But first, Colonel looking away.
Colonel's blushing.
Colonel, he's like...
The bright dot in the middle is you, Snake.
That's me.
The red dots are your enemies.
And the blue cone shape represents their field of vision.
Okay, get out of here.
Be careful, Snake.
The genome soldiers have highly developed senses of hearing
and vision due to their gene therapy.
Make sure you don't let them see you.
Okay.
First, I want you to infiltrate the disposal site and look
for the DARPA chief.
The diaper chief was the same GPS transmitting nanomachines
as you.
Highly developed.
He should appear on your radar as a green dot.
Get whatever information you can from him about the
terrorists.
Okay.
If he's alive, that is.
Oh, he's fine.
He's okay.
He's fine.
Why did you guys say it like that?
But if you're discovered by an enemy, he won't be able to
use it.
I think we need to upgrade our technology.
It gets jammed easily, I'm afraid.
Yes, it's all made from currently existing technology.
I think we need to upgrade that.
use it in an area with strong harmonic resonance so be
careful be careful we'll be monitoring your movements by
radar nanomachines mint contact us by codec anytime you want
got it i'll call if i'm feeling lonely seriously snake we're
here to back you up so call if you need some information or
advice okay i'm also in charge of your mission data contact
me if you want me to save your current status my frequency
is 140.96 one four zero point nine six one four zero point
nine 6 everybody don't forget it don't forget it except for
your binoculars you need to arm yourself with whatever
weapons you can find i remember first i'm strip searched by
dr naomi here and then all my weapons are taken away what
weapons did you have yourself put in that position one four
zero point nine six maybe i'll let you do a strip search on
me hold you to that doctor by the way sorry to disappoint
you but I did manage to smuggle out my smokes not in this
how did you do that he ate them thanks to the shot you gave
me that suppressed my stomach acids cigarettes how are those
going to help you you never know hey this guy is so dumb oh
my god he's so dumb there's the front door there's the door
snake but there's the door.
Which way should we go?
I'm probably going to go in the way that I that way.
Yeah, that one.
One sentry on the left and one on the right.
But we already have our gun.
We can take these guys out, I think.
There should also be a duct on the second floor.
Also, since this is like MGS2, you can hold them up, right?
Oh, but I've been trying to practice how to hold up people,
but I'm still not really good it is.
So, uh, I'll do my best.
The pineapples.
Pineapple, pineapple.
There's nothing over here, right?
I don't remember there being anything over here.
Um, okay, let's see.
Uh, I'm assuming the zoom is the same.
Okay, yes.
And then it's X.
I'm like, I was, okay, There's that guy over there.
There's a guy up there.
Yeah, there's obviously the spotlight's in the middle, but
there's a guy over here.
That's our sleeping body.
Oh, but there's also the camera here.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
Okay, so A, and then Z.
Okay, we'll get this, we'll get this, you guys.
Can I run, oh my gosh, how am I supposed to run though?
How am I supposed to, oh, what?
There's auto aim?
Yo, no way!
Oh, oh, oh, hold on, okay, wait, my fingers are all messed
up right now, okay.
I almost had him.
I could have gotten him.
But if he faint right now, they'll notice I'm here.
Do you think it's too far away?
I think it's too far.
I can't tell.
How am I supposed to walk when I have all this?
How am I supposed to do this?
Okay, hold on.
She's hacking.
Aimbot.
Let's get this guy.
Never mind.
Let's get him.
I can't tell if it's too far or not.
It looks way too far, right?
Okay, wait.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm just getting a feel for things, guys.
I'm just getting a feel for things.
Okay, so the quick...
Oh, okay.
The quick...
Oh, this is...
Oh, oh, oh, interesting.
Okay, so if I hold...
If I push down...
Ah!
I didn't mean to do that.
If I push down, it brings up the menu.
I can do that.
It's like not so...
Or it's...
Okay.
We're learning.
What is...
What is crawling?
Oh my god!
Nope.
No, no, no.
Get up, Snake.
There's nobody here.
Snake, we're still learning the controls.
We can't do this yet.
Oh.
Wait, I can't move in first.
Okay.
You can't walk in first person?
Why did I think I could?
Unless it's just holding my gun.
No!
Come back!
Please!
Okay.
Whose footprints are these?
No one's, uh...
It's your imagination.
No one's, no one's, no one's.
Do I have to equip it before I go into first person?
Okay.
Come here, mister.
I'm gonna get your butt.
Come on.
Oh, there you are.
I don't think...
Oh, I did get him.
I don't have very many bullets left.
And he's down.
Then this is what makes the game a little bit easier because
of the first person stuff, you know.
Come here.
Do you think I can get him?
Oh, I got him.
Go down.
There you go.
I will learn.
A surveillance camera.
Oh, no, I got the wrong one.
What?
Oh, I can see.
They're...
What's it called?
It's range.
Is that gun still in here?
Or...
Oh yeah, there we go.
Okay, nice.
A surveillance camera.
Okay, that guy...
Go back to sleep.
Go to sleep, little baby.
Oh.
Uh...
We'll get him from this side.
Close.
Oh, I need to equip the gun.
go to sleep go to sleep little baby go to sleep um now how
do I crawl okay crawl is this there we go go did I forget
did I forget anything?
I don't remember did I forget it's fine if I forgot some
items we got the SOCOM though so we We can perform violence.
But the M9 has the suppressor.
Gosh, it makes it so easy.
Hello?
Where's the rats?
Natskashi!
Wait, where's the item?
They took away.
Wasn't there a ration down here?
Violence!
Thank you!
Thanks for the down low.
They took away my...
Null rats.
Follow the mice.
Where are they?
I only have three bullets left.
Maybe we need to be...
Oh, there they are!
Peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, oh, uh...
Oh, it did it by itself.
Okay, thank you.
Yes!
Master Miller!
Oh my god, Master Miller!
I quit being a boot camp instructor, so I moved out here for
some peace and quiet.
I'm in retirement, just like you.
Just, just, he's in retirement.
Once in a while, I still help train the Alaskan scouts.
Passing on the skills to a new generation, huh?
Campbell told me about the situation here.
I thought I might be of some use.
What skills does Kaz have?
There's no one I'd rather have in a foxhole.
I'm actually legitimately...
I actually don't know.
survival in a harsh environment.
I've never seen Kaz on the floor.
He's always like...
Burgers.
My frequency is 141.80.
Those mice are Alaskan field mice.
Don't worry.
They can't hurt you.
Thanks, Master.
Wild field mice don't have a thick layer of fat, but they
can still survive the bitter winters here without
hibernating.
They dig tunnels under the snow.
That's where they stay warm.
Survival Specialist.
Start and A?
But there's a dark side too.
A dark side.
Sometimes the males will kill and eat offspring that are not
their own.
Are you sure they're not a danger?
To ensure the survival of their own genes, right?
Yeah.
Pretty brilliant program, huh?
If there are mice, that means there must be an exit
somewhere.
Follow the mice.
What is it?
Uh...
Start plus A.
Okay.
Oh wait, it's already put in there.
Well, we should save anyway.
Sorry, the Soliton radar won't work in a narrow space.
Never mind.
Too much harmonic resonance.
The radio waves produce interference and we can't analyze
the topographic data.
Oh wait.
Try to hang on until you get to a more open space, okay?
Oh, wait, we're fine.
Just kidding.
New file.
Okay, beep, beep.
Don't give up, Snake.
Thanks mailing!
Wait, where's my...
Um, excuse me.
Where is my... where is my proverb?
Didn't realize you like this franchise?
Be cautious about the brain rot?
AP.
AP, it's over for me.
It's...
When did I tell us...
Those mice...
Oh, yeah.
When do we learn Nastassha's?
I don't remember hers, actually.
What was it?
What was hers?
My link sounds different without an accent.
Yeah, 141.52.
Oh.
This is Nastassha Romanenko.
A pleasure to work with you, Salad Snake.
Nastassha!
You are the nuclear specialist that the Colonel mentioned.
That's me.
You can ask me anything about nukes that you want.
I am also a military analyst.
So sad she never got like a...
3D model.
She's so hot.
They asked me to participate in this operation as a
supervisor from the nuclear emergency search team.
She still has her accent, but it's...
It's muted.
It's way less.
I hope I can help you to stop them.
You're a tough lady.
You're a tough lady!
Those terrorists are serious about launching a nuclear
weapon.
The world cannot stand by idly and allow that to happen.
yeah it's much more subdued all i can do from here is
provide you with information thank you nastasha that'll be
enough another soldier here wouldn't make a difference
anyway it's good to work with you nastasha same here snake
yeah yeah you can hear it there right okay start a button so
strange all right little rats let's go let's go little rats
oh oh yes the water oh my god oh But, but, but, but, but,
but, but, but, but, but, but, why is it going down so fast?
Stop, that's so messed up.
I can't believe I lost health.
Mew, meew, meew, meew, meew.
Mew, weew, weew, weew.
Weew, this should be an exit right here.
Oh, no, it is not.
Interesting.
Okay.
Where do they want me to exit then from?
Hello?
variant?
Aha!
I should have followed the rat.
Did that hit him?
Uh-oh, I only have one bullet left.
Good night!
How do I get up?
Shit.
Okay.
I'll start and start, eh.
to change floors.
There should be a cargo elevator that you can take down
somewhere around there.
How do I pick them up?
Try to find it.
How do I, uh...
How do I pick them up for the loot?
Yeah, like if I can shake the bodies in two, right, it's the
same thing?
What do I...
Is it...
Maybe A?
A or B?
Let's try.
A.
Oh, there we go.
Give me all you got.
okay he's got nothing lame ass
oh the music in here is so okay nothing in here
I should also have my ration equipment yeah let's help that
was so close I don't know where he goes
oh um can I get out of here please thank you
how do i want to take this guy out
okay how do i uh okay hold on all right if i run up to it
behind him and then do that oh no
oh i could still hold it up they don't know i have zero
bullets right time to bluff Okay.
Is there anyone?
I think there's a guy upstairs, right?
So he'll hear me.
Oh, man.
Okay, okay, let's see.
He comes around.
We'll wait for him.
I'm going to lose my brain.
Please.
Please, please!
Go in there, snake.
Oh, why, why, why, why, why, why, why do I just let go of
the button?
Why do I, why do I just let go of the button?
Ah, it's so...
Blah!
Actually, this works though.
Can you just lift up just a tiny bit, snake?
They're gonna know, they're never gonna stop leaving me
alone, then they're never gonna leave me alone!
You can go away now.
Did he pull out his, uh, he pulled out his shield?
The other guy is still asleep.
That's some strong...
180 IQ everybody.
Are their legs okay now?
The guy's snoring up a storm over here.
Don't wake him up, though, please.
Oh, take it.
Please, I have no more gun.
No more bullets.
Okay.
You guys, this is just all so familiar, isn't it?
Come on.
Leave me alone.
Hello?
No more gun.
Can I still use it, though?
Even if it's empty?
Oh, I could still bluff.
perhaps I can make them lay down maybe
yeah get out of here attack team get out of here okay that
guy is the one that patrols over on that side then we're
gonna have our other friend who walks around this tank I
think is what he does oh hello they're both on the right
side where are you there's that okay okay if I can okay
let's try it let's try this out
you jerk oh oh dang it's the enemy sick you say
grab them Wait, ah,
oh my god, they're so loud.
You know what, let's just kill them.
Or let them kill me.
It's fine.
You guys can just kill me.
In fact, I'll help you.
Let's restart.
Okay.
Okay, it's okay because I didn't even have any bullets.
Okay, we're gonna sneak up on him and we're gonna...
We're gonna get his butt.
The controls.
It's okay.
One left!
Wait, only one?
I had two before.
Hey, game!
I had two before!
You know?
It's not really fair, I'm just saying.
If I had taken him down, the other guy would have seen him
faint.
Maybe he'll come back.
Okay, let's see, where are you?
Where did he go?
Where does he walk to?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
It's X to get up.
Is this about the elevator?
Thank you.
You guys...
There we go.
Oh, my...
The other guy's gonna come, though!
Uh, shoot.
um you're supposed to why didn't you shake down why didn't
you shake your little boonies why did you shake your little
boonies and get on the ground
uh wait oh shit oh yeah kill me again actually just take me
out you have to be in front of him
I want him to get on the ground okay let's try well I was
gonna kill him but we won't kill him and I won't waste this
point maybe we just go upstairs you know what maybe we don't
even care about these guys or wait the elevator we got to go
down to get to i need more bullets though we need to go
upstairs and kind of loot the place a little bit i don't
think you can make them lie down though not in this one
maybe not because they're supposed to like chill there and
be like okay oh my
the get up button i i seriously cannot because the a button
is so big it's so big my fingers just instinctively click it
it's so just kill me kill me who's that dang
oh i almost had you
oh okay
There he is!
Radar, it's picking up the DARPA chief.
He's the green dot.
Hurry and rescue him.
Hurry and rescue him!
Okay.
Um, oh, this is first person.
There's no one over here, though.
There's the guy in here, but we can't go in there.
Blup, blup.
I know to press the action button, Colonel.
Pressing while holding the A will put down the gun without
shooting.
I thought you had to unequip the...
Whoa, I can't see anything.
Oh, there we go.
I thought you had to unequip it so that it wouldn't shoot.
What's this?
It's a sparrow.
Sneaky, sneaky.
Oh!
Oh, it's Johnny.
I hate Alaska.
Why do I have to see this?
Ow, gross.
Ew, it's so steamy.
That woman is built all right.
Boy, oh boy.
That sound like goofy.
That woman is built all right.
Johnny, my man.
Let's get our bullets.
Yay!
First.
First person down?
Wait.
Oh.
There's no one in there.
What?
What is that?
Are you playing naughty games at work?
Oh, wrong way.
There we go.
Snake is such a voyeur.
Oh, gross!
We don't even know be flushed.
We definitely know he didn't wash his hands.
Oh, there is a dirty magazine.
Nice.
Merrill, I'm coming for you.
Are you still doing sit-ups like you always do?
It's weird that it forces... Oh, hello.
forces you into the cutscene.
There she is.
Merle.
A woman.
Not him.
Oh, really?
Really, Snake?
Oh, my gosh.
Don't look up, Merle.
Don't look up.
Don't.
I'm just going to completely forget about what the colonel
said about, uh...
about um you know his niece and all of that you know how
does she not see him i know he's just that sneaky
who's that who's that who's that i'm here to save you you're
the DARPA chief donald anderson right the diaper chief
that's my favorite character you guys You're here to save
me, huh?
What's your outfit?
Uh, Louis Vuitton.
I'm the pawn they sent in here to save your worthless butt.
Greg Eagles.
It's true.
You don't look like one of them.
In that case, hurry up and get me out of here.
Slow down.
No, guys.
The diaper chief in this very cell.
This...
Guy standing before us.
He's my favorite character.
Just this diaper chief right here.
The terrorists are threatening the White House.
They say if they don't exceed to their demands, they'll
launch a nuclear weapon.
Oh no!
Oh, LMAO.
Sweet Jesus.
Is it possible?
well it's possible they could launch a nuke oh my god whoa
whoa i'm getting oh my god i'm getting how do they plan to
launch how about this place was just for the keeping of
distant warrants they shouldn't have access to a whiplash
i'm getting motion sick you guys that's the official story
got it we were conducting exercises with a new type of
experimental weapon a truly historical weapon metal gear
what whoa wait the ability to launch a nuclear attack from
any place on the face of the earth miss girly kicked out do
we get the real-life picture metal gear metal gear you knew
metal gear is one of the most secret black projects how did
you know that how did I do know that.
We've had a couple of run-ins in the past.
Not with this little guy.
She's so cute!
Why else would I come to a godless second place like this?
Oh my god, little Rex.
Ow!
I had heard that the Metal Gear project was scrapped.
Oh my god, show the other side.
On the contrary, it's grown into a huge joint project
between arms taken ourselves.
Show the laser.
Ow!
His little...
Oh, he's so cute!
Guys in the mouth.
Oh my god.
Tiny arms.
Is this Grim from Grim Adventures of Billy Mandy?
Yes, it is.
You can hear it, right?
You can hear it a little bit.
It's so funny.
Rex has fallen into the hands of terrorists.
Little by.
Metal Gear Rex.
The codename for the new Metal Gear prototype.
They're probably already finished.
Johnny's just like, shut the hell up in there.
They're all experienced in handling and equipping nuclear
weapons.
Maybe you shouldn't...
Shut up in there, will ya?
Maybe Snake shouldn't be standing in front of the door, you
know?
Maybe, like...
Yeah, whatever.
Oh,
where could he be?
equipped with safety measures some kind of detonation what
are you doing up there oh you mean pal pal pal yes of course
there is a pal it's not a pal though it's set up so that you
need to input two different passwords in order to launch the
device there are two passwords yes baker knows one and i
know one baker the president of arms tech that's right but
did you talk each of us needs
don't say that he's no pal either look at the membership
thank you so much let me on thank you oh you're so weak
you're weak psycho mantis can read people's minds you can't
resist no you had the train one of the members of Foxhound
yeah you know that he has psychic powers you just said that
password 1 2 3 no no oh my god she's the sweat if they find
out baker's password yes they'll be able to launch a nuke
anytime anytime but there is a way to stop the launch what
but card keys card keys card keys they were designed by arms
tech the system developers as an emergency override even
without the passwords you can just insert the card keys and
engage the safety lock mm-hmm and if I do that sounds easy
enough right guys yes you can stop the launch look at her
that card key so where are the card keys Baker should have
them listen you need three card keys there are different
slots to put them in easy peasy okay okay three card keys
three card keys you know where they might be keeping baker
somewhere in the second floor basement second floor basement
second floor basement i heard the guards say they moved them
into an area that has a lot of electronic jamming so pretty
any other clues yes they cemented over the entrances but
didn't have enough time to paint the walls are a different
color got it oh yippee take this oh wow it's my id card
it'll open any level one why do you only have a level one
security card it's called a pan card that is insane together
with your body's own electrical field personal area network
huh it transmits data using the salts in your body as a
transmission medium wow as you approach the door security
devices thank you so much and the doors will open
automatically gotcha he's just the DARPA chief after all
yeah it's not even that big of a his bandana is so flowy
it's so great you haven't heard any other way to disarm the
pal have you from your bosses or anyone no no are you sure
you haven't heard anything I just said no so does the White
House plan to give in to the terrorist demands hey that's
Not our problem.
It has nothing to do with my orders.
But what about the Pentagon?
Hmm?
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Oh, his tummy!
Oh, no!
What is it?
I'm- Ow!
Oh my god, he's so scary looking.
IBS?
He's got tummy issues!
The toilet's right there!
Ah!
Hey, what happened?
Charlie, stop making a scene!
Stop making a scene!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
He's really dragging this now.
Here.
Oh!
He's still going.
He's earning that Oscar.
Oh!
Wait, his eyes turn black?
Yamcha
is he gonna grab him and go for a second round huh dead we
just shut his eyes it looked like they went like like like
he's wearing sclera lenses great observation snake huh Naomi
the chief what happened I I don't know it looked like a
heart attack but a heart attack no no colonel are you hiding
something for money no absolutely not you've got to
understand this counter terrorist op a security level red
you'll need the highest security clearance to learn the real
story you want me to believe that you just told me that you
are hiding something and I have to play the game to unlock
it the secretary of defense is in operational control I'm
just Just here is your support.
Uh-huh.
Snake, we don't have time to debate.
Yeah.
Get out of there and find President Baker.
What do you mean by that?
You mean it wasn't a heart attack.
Why would you say the real story?
Real story is you just had a heart attack, right?
That's all.
Oh, uh...
This one.
Thank you!
Oh?
I hear her getting zipped up.
Oh, sorry.
How you doing down there?
Oh, there she goes!
Oh!
Pretty suspicious!
She's waiting for me!
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, I really...
Thank you!
Hope that you read this portable... MGS portable ops quote.
You've given me a real reason to fight Limit Boss.
Thank you.
Okay.
X is to crouch.
X is to crouch and B is to fight X is to crouch Y is action
X is to crouch is to crouch crouch X is to crouch B is to
fight X is to crouch and B is to fight X is to crouch and B
is to fight and don't click the big a unless you mean it
okay hmm
Actually, I was told to try something in this next part.
I want to kind of try it out.
Don't move.
So you killed the chief, you bastard.
No, it wasn't me.
It was IBS.
It's really serious.
It's plaguing the nation.
No, you're not.
Don't move.
No, I'm solid.
this the first time you ever pointed a gun at a person your
hands are shaking your hands are shaking got you got your
nose oh oh oh where did that come from can you shoot me
rookie careful i've got rookie's eyes rookie i mean she's
got rookie's eyes liar your eyes wander there's no
confidence in them the eyes of a rookie the eyes of a rookie
never shot a person have you you talk too much you haven't
even taken the safety off rookie I told you I'm no rookie oh
no you're not one of them are you open that door oh it's
Johnny so we can get the hell out of here be a little
delayed Foxhound don't think shoot oh
you know what mind it didn't work at all what I was told to
do didn't work at all well maybe if I anyway how do I shoot
why aren't you shooting at me why aren't you shooting at all
oh what are you waiting for shoot don't talk to me like a
rookie I'm telling you shoot
Oh, gosh, dang it.
They did it to me again.
Oh, my gosh.
Hold on.
I need to...
Oh, gosh.
It's so...
Oh, my God.
No!
Oh, I'm out!
No way.
What?
Girlie, you need to handle this by yourself.
I'm sorry.
I'm out of bullets.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, there they are.
Never mind.
I got them.
We're back.
We're back, everybody.
oh two two two oh good job really oh
oh shoot oh where did the grenade go oh it
doesn't help when the um it kind of like what's the word it
kind of auto aims so even if i go for the head it like aims
down you see that like so it's uh i don't know if there's a
way to turn that off
yeah i saw it move yeah so like it if i'm trying to aim it
tries to like move down a little it makes it more difficult
oh yes girl auto miss who are you oh we
Oh, just kidding.
You fool!
You've killed him!
I'm sorry, sir.
His mental shielding was very strong.
I could not dive into his mind.
Oh my god, he sounds so awesome.
You fool!
Who did they kill?
now we'll never get that detonation code oh wait what boss I
have a good idea
what it was Baker whoa what am I doing oh my god look at her
go yeah oh Whoa!
Go save!
Oh yeah!
Dodged every single one Like a true champion Isn't doesn't
she pose there in the original doesn't she like kind of
Psycho Mantis
Wait Thank you Are you saying that to me or snake?
I mean, wait, are you saying that to Merrill or snake?
Not me, sorry.
Got a little.
A little, you know.
Naomi, I just had some kind of hallucination.
Naomi, I'm going kind of crazy.
Self-insert caught.
No.
It's coming from Psycho Mantis.
Foxhound's psychic.
Think of it as a mental feedback loop.
So that was Mantis.
I would say that that scene...
It doesn't spoil, but it does...
Oh, I'm bleeding out.
Um, snake.
There we go.
There you go.
Stop bleeding!
Stop!
You're getting your messy!
You're messying up the floor!
We're good?
Okay.
Uh, oh, they're all gone even.
Well, almost.
Anything under here I can't remember.
Nope.
But there is stuff in here that we saw in the pot.
Wait, is there anything in here?
Oh, ha ha.
Very good.
Hacking.
What is it?
Is that the nuclear warheads building?
No.
Oh, no.
This is the first... Okay, wait.
Because that looks like the tank.
And then... Okay.
No, this is just the building that we're in.
Oh, I see it.
We are missions.
No, I think that top one is the floor we were just at the
floor you sneak into and then the second right but then
there but there's no tank on this floor i don't know
actually i don't think there is what's this one six and then
there's nothing else right
wait what is this oh come on thank Re-angle.
Re-re-re-adjust.
Okay, there we go.
Just unequip the gun.
Unequip the gun, mint!
X is for shooting.
I mean, no, X is for crawling!
Oh my god.
X is for crawling.
B is for fight.
There's nothing under the desk, is there?
Actually, I didn't think about it.
X is for crawling.
A is to shoot.
And X is to crawl.
A is to shoot, and you shoot good.
Unequip if you don't want to waste your bullet.
I'm going to check under the desk real quick.
Oh, oh.
What the?
Oh, I was like, what is that spinning thing on the radar?
But it's thingy.
That's so funny.
Nothing.
Let's get out of here.
So now we...
Go fight.
Aw.
Now we go fight.
Well, first we go explode.
Beep.
I remember some of the guard chokeout noises in this game
being particularly over the top and silly if you want a good
laugh.
I...
Chris?
Thank you.
Not backseating at all.
I'm letting you know.
I'm trying.
I'm so bad at getting the guys sometimes.
Not sometimes.
Like, almost all the time.
But, you know.
Um.
Which floors cave in?
Uh, let's, um...
Uh, start A.
Um.
What is it, Snake?
Hey, I'm just saving for no big reason.
Not that I think I'm gonna...
Why can't I be, like, riding and do a little cart flip...
Cart wheel over it, you know?
Thank you.
Snake, like Shakespeare said, knots had all spent.
First they take your accents and now you're quoting a
Western guy?
No!
That goes for items too.
Don't get too greedy or you might be sorry.
Be careful, Snake.
I hate that one.
I'm not gonna listen.
I should... I feel like I should be calling codec more
because i don't know how many things are different but also
it's fun to talk to them right try to think your mind is
your most dangerous weapon he's telling me i'm dumb try to
simplify your thoughts i'm simplifying try calling campbell
for advice thank you thank you so much nastasha what do you
have to say they were conducting exercises with this new
metal gear prototype is that what the darpa chief said yeah
it is what the hell so you know about metal gear what the
hell just rumors i heard it was some kind of walking tank
that can deliver an accurate nuclear strike from any terrain
mountains desert swamps wherever wherever whatever whatever
as long as metal gear i'll be here and you'll be near but
what about the pal system that the darpa chief mentioned it
is a device attached to a nuclear weapon system to prevent
the missile from being armed or launched Usually a secret
detonation code or combination is necessary to launch the
missile.
The missile.
According to the chief, there are two codes and the
terrorists already know one of them.
Uh-oh.
The other code.
If the terrorists find out that one too.
Do they, though?
Yeah.
Because he's dead.
I gotta hurry and rescue President Baker.
Do they know?
Because one of them is dead.
Okay.
I don't remember.
Let's try down here.
Run!
Uh, three.
Is this a trap?
Wow!
That actually makes your health go down way faster than it
did before.
Is this one a trap?
Well, no.
No, it's not, because we need the sea floor.
Right?
You know what?
I'm just gonna crawl anyway.
Crawl, crawl, crawl.
Crawl, crawl.
Crawl, crawl, crawl, crawl.
Oh, don't get up, Snake.
Crawl, crawl, crawl.
Just in case.
I don't think it is, though.
Oh, I think we're good.
Hula!
Am I gonna regret this later?
More C4!
Nice.
Wait, there's so much C4.
Uh...
I think we...
Oopsie.
Run!
Oh, I thought that...
I thought that was a hole.
One.
Grenades?
Is this what a trap?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh.
Is this one a trap?
It says no smoking.
I can't...
Wait.
Why is she paranoid?
Because sometimes there's traps.
Wait, that's two of them.
Wait, did that say Famous?
Oh!
Guess we know where to get the Famous.
Wait, are they all labeled?
That's so cute.
Grenade?
Okay, does this one...
PSG?
Were they C4?
Were they labeled...
Uh, what is that one?
Nikita?
Were they labeled in the first game too?
I just never noticed?
Nikita.
Oh, cool.
How nice of them.
Now I'm pretty sure this one falls.
Yeah!
Run, snake, run!
Okay.
Run!
The place to blow it up is...
Step back a little bit.
Oh!
Wait, is there just the door?
Beep, beep.
What's this one?
Two.
Oh wait, I don't know where it is then in this one, right?
Mm-hmm.
Oh, there!
It does look like a different color.
Just kidding.
Okay, C4.
How to use.
Press A button to set.
B button to detonate.
Easy.
How do I do the book?
Adult-oriented material full of girly photos and interesting
columns.
I'm running around with my book.
I like the music here.
Uh...
Okay.
Whoa!
There we go.
Didn't have time to paint it, eh?
What were you gonna paint it anyway?
Concrete color?
How do you...
How do you paint it?
Wait, hold on.
Let me make sure.
Set to A.
Okay, A to set.
Run, run, run, run, run, Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Concrete gray.
And then those two.
A to set.
This is Ocelot.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, he looks...
He looks kind of naked in this position.
He looks a little...
Oh, there we go.
Wait, why is his jacket like over top his body?
Were you cold, President Baker?
Were you cold?
Did they give you a little jacket to help you stay warm?
actually that's even wait his arm sleeves are like they're
flapping everywhere there it's more of a liability because
it's gonna like what if those what if the breeze oh my god
they're gonna touch the wires it is alaska you're right
you're right you're right okay um i'm gonna call real quick
we're gonna save.
Okay, Acelot time, baby.
Snake, you can't use your radar.
Yeah, I know.
Oh, we're fine.
Don't worry about it.
New file.
Yes.
Bidding!
Okay, B.
Alright.
Be careful, Snake.
Thanks, Mealing.
Wait, I'm gonna go get those grenades.
I don't think I need them right now, but you know what?
I will go get them.
Just a half.
As Shakespeare said, You can't use the radar.
What if this is what she meant, though?
As in, like, you can't get everything you want.
You can't always get what you want.
Okay, those were fine.
And it was this one, too, right?
I'm so calm.
And I think we're safe.
I think we're safe.
I'm so scared.
Lots of so-called bullets.
Very good.
Okay, cool.
Perfect.
The first person makes it easier compared to the original.
Oh, yeah.
It really does.
I think it's just for me the controller is the more
difficult thing.
Well, actually...
Um, the easiest way that I've played the game, well, well,
Metal Gear Solid 1, I've done my best, like, my best
performance, quote-unquote performance, playing the Switch
version, which is absolutely wild, I think.
Um, but, I don't know.
I don't know why it was so easy for me on a TDR mat.
You'll get used to it.
Yeah, yeah, I will, uh...
I will practice with it some more and stuff.
I gotta get used to, like, the first person being here and
then...
Okay, we don't need to crouch in this, so...
And we don't need to kick fight.
We just gotta...
We just gotta shoot.
Hopefully we can actually shoot him in the head, though.
Oh, my God.
Your sleeves, be careful!
Oh!
My God!
he's alive yep astute observation snake you're the arms tech
president kenneth baker right president baker don't worry
i'm here to save you no don't don't touch it
well you're the one who was coughing like crazy mister c4 c4
your cough
my controller is going crazy right touch that wire in the C4
oh my god so you're the one that the boss keeps talking
about look at the way he's standing he's so sassy and you
and you special operations foxhound revolver Yes, keep
going, King.
Keep going.
Yes!
Dramatic pause.
Oh my god, okay.
Yes.
Yes, don't stop.
Oh, Salon.
Yes!
Oh, yes, keep it up.
Oh my god, he's so awesome.
I've been waiting for you, Solid Snake.
Oh, I bet you have.
We'll see if the man can live up to the legend.
Shadashaskan.
Don't, don't, don't, don't.
This is the greatest handgun ever made.
The cult single action army.
Six bullets.
anything that moves yeah he said the thing
stares at him just kind of like why are you putting your gun
away you idiot don't let your guard down what do you mean
now i'll show you why they call me revolver
yeah that's a lot
drug yeah okay How to do this with first person.
Where is he?
Oh, hold on.
Let me draw.
Where are you?
Where are you anyway?
Oh.
Hello?
He's reloading.
I'm alive.
No.
Ocelot.
This is too easy.
No
way!
You're pretty good.
Just what I'd expect from the man with the same code as the
boss.
It's been a long time since I had such a good fight.
That was a good fight.
You're so right.
Just getting warmed up.
Ah!
This is, that is actually one of the bigger criticisms.
of this game is that the boss fights tend to be too easy
because watch
poor president Baker is just like oh god that's a cool shot
Speed running the fight with Ocelot for real.
This one is really easy to cheese and um, what's his name?
Uh, Vulcan Raven is very easy to cheese.
Allegedly.
You're that ninja!
Can't you even die right?
After standing mostly still and getting shot seven times,
you're pretty good.
You were lucky.
We'll meet again.
You know what I just realized?
Snake's got those Kimpossible lips.
Do you see it?
I want to hear what he sounds like.
I like you.
I have no name.
Oh, he sounds so cool though.
I mean, it's... I get that, like it's sad that I'm glad it's
not Greg Eagles, but...
What the voice...
What the...
What's it called?
The voice effect over top.
Wait, what did it say?
What was it saying?
Whoa.
Sounds like a ride.
Do you think so?
Oh, no!
Oh my god, he's going crazy.
Oh, oh, the fight with him is probably going to be so...
Wow!
Slow motion bullets!
What?
What was that implying?
Oh, he was cutting the top!
Oh, he cut the top of the building just to kick it at Snake!
No way!
The tension.
Bye!
Oh, oh, it's a little messy, but okay.
Who the hell?
It's like if I'm controlling him, how do they make my man
even more Chuni?
Because the man describing these events is absolute.
Otaku freak!
Can you talk?
Who are you?
I'm not one of them.
I like this part too.
The way Snake reacts in this part makes me laugh.
What about yours?
Oh, I get it.
Jim sent you.
Oh, Jim.
Answer my question.
What about your code?
There's no time.
I talked.
Oh, you weak.
Now the terrorists have both codes and can launch any time.
These cutscenes are crazy.
It's not like I didn't fight.
It is.
I managed to resist Psycho Mantis' mind probe.
He couldn't read you.
How'd you do it?
Surgical implants in my brain.
Oh.
Surgical implants.
Kind of like psychic insulation.
Everyone who knows these top secret codes has it.
Wow.
Even the DARPA chief?
Of course.
Done.
The chief said Mantis got his code by reading his mind.
Are you sure you heard him right?
Hmm.
Yeah.
Anyway, how did they get your code?
Yeah, why'd you talk, buddy?
I never had any training on how to resist torture.
Yeah.
It looks like you had some fun with you, all right.
It's just a little torture.
He's not human.
loved every second of it he's such a freak he broke it oh
looks like you're more than even now his was sliced off the
effects you're a funny guy so he is the DARPA chief is he
okay dead dead what it can't be he's a little quirky yeah
that's not Would you promise, Jim?
Now you want to shut me out?
Calm down.
Come, be done.
What's wrong with you?
I just told you I was here to save you.
I didn't kill the DARPA chief.
He had a heart attack or something.
A heart attack?
Oh, don't be a fool.
Lucky Baker.
Paris have both codes now.
Oh, those boys are totally insane.
They wouldn't hesitate to launch.
I agree.
But what do they really want?
What do they really want?
Who knows?
Maybe they're like us in the arms industry.
Thank you so much.
Always looking forward to the next good war.
Well, I'm not going to let these maniacs start a war today.
Not today.
have the card keys card keys give me a card key to override
the detonation code I heard you had them no definitely not a
god-bad what who does then not the terrorists no that that
that woman woman who the one with the nice soldier that was
thrown in prison along with me prison that female soldier
hmm she said that She had just joined up as a new recruit.
This girl is a thorn in my side.
Because she refused to take part in the rebellion.
A new recruit.
Could that be the colonel's niece?
I gave her the key.
Looks like she managed to break out of here, though.
I hope she's okay.
I gotta go to the bathroom after this part.
She's green, but as tough as they come.
But how did you know she escaped?
contact with her by codec oh this part this is the part that
i like tied up here that is because in the original it's
like the goblet of fire part we're in the book dumbledore
reacts so calmly but in the movie he's crazy if she still
has it you should be able to contact her in the original he
acts like sure she has it this one he acts so crazy oh yeah
give her code let me tell you it's he's
Huh?
Oh Sorry, I forgot Damn
Oh, that's right It should be on the back of the package Try
to contact her I'll contact her right away.
In the original he's just like damn and like kind of like
hits his knee To prevent the missile launch and this one he
acts like an actual lunatic You need to find Howe Emmerich,
one of my employees.
Howe Emmerich?
The team leader of the Metal Gear Rex project.
A genius in engineering, but a little bit of an oddball.
A little bit of an oddball, you guys.
If there's anyone who can figure out how to stop Metal Gear
from launching, it's him.
What if he can't come up with anything?
Well, you'll have to destroy it.
Emmerich knows how to destroy Metal Gear.
Where is this Emmerich?
well he's probably being held somewhere in the nuclear
warhead storage building it's it's north from here that's
where he worked got it I understand but why metal gear the
nuclear age ended with the turn of the Millennium oh you're
wrong the nuclear threat hasn't disappeared the threat is
more real than ever before it's so icky the amount of spent
nuclear fuel and plutonium is increasing even today real
footage oh you're pretty good thank you drums and drums of
nuclear waste stack this high as far as you can see because
there's still no real way to use it or dispose of it so they
just close the lid and try to it'll go away essentially yes
wow and they're not even doing a good job of storing it no
oh there's just people right there with nuclear waste
seeping out of them unbelievable unbelievable several pounds
of muff were reported every year not the muff it stands for
material unaccounted for it proves that there's a large and
well-organized black market in nuclear materials furthermore
since the end of the Cold War, Russian nuclear engineers in
particular are out of work with nowhere to turn.
Hey, I beat him that quickly because I'm good at the game.
There's plenty of available nuclear material and scientists
for making a bomb.
We live in an age where any small country can have a nuclear
weapons program.
What about the other superpowers?
The Russians and Chinese still pursue a policy of
deterrence.
Deterrence.
Do you see?
The complete nuclear disarmament is an impossibility.
Oh, deterrence.
To maintain our own policy of deterrence.
We need a weapon of overwhelming power.
The Peace Walker flashbacks.
You need metal gear.
Oh my god, Rex is so cute.
You know our industry suffered quite a blow as a result of
the cuts in military budgets due to this so-called peace.
I remember hearing a lot about mergers and takeovers.
Oh, I missed the Ocelot boss fight.
It lasted like 15 seconds.
I lost their bid to produce the U.S.
Air Forces next lie in a fighter jet.
The Metal Gear system was our last ace in the hole.
That's why we pushed to have Metal Gear developed as a black
project.
Black project.
Secret projects paid for by the Pentagon's black budget.
Yeah, that's what the DARPA chief talked about earlier.
You can avoid a lot of red tape and get a great lead time on
your weapons production.
You avoid the red tape because you use black instead.
It's a common secret.
It's a well-known secret.
Bribes.
Just call it the military-industrial complex.
Anyway, Metal Gear was going to be formally adopted.
After the results of this exercise were analyzed.
I don't give a crap about you or your company.
Yeah.
Yes, that's about what I'd expect from a grunt like you.
Like Victoria's secret?
you came for right oh thanks finally what's that an optical
disc it's all here don't give me your hard drive was
destroyed by gunfire this is the only remaining copy of the
data what kind of data all the data collected from this
exercise don't play dumb I know you were sent to get this I
hid it from that sadistic maniac while he was torturing me
where'd you hide it know this dis exists make sure that you
report this to jim where did you hide that to your boss
where did you hide that i'll give you my card too it'll open
up all security level two doors between the cheeks
i love how flowy his uh his bandana is so fun to look at you
go on without me oh my stomach got my password they don't
want anything else for me I have one more question.
Do you have IBS?
Who or what was that ninja thing?
It looked like you knew something.
Did it?
That ninja?
That was Foxhound's dark little secret.
Dark little secret?
I'll keep you my dark little secret.
Soldier.
Don't tell anyone or you'll be.
You know him?
You should ask Dr. Naohy.
hunter from Foxhound she knows better than I Naomi you've
got to stop them if it goes public my just my company and I
are finished what doesn't metal gear use currently existing
technology metal gear itself does but oh he's turning greed
what did Oh my god, he ate the blueberry from Willy Wonka!
Oh!
He's turning into... What's a grape?
Why is he so green?
He's hulking out.
He went and did it.
Oh.
What are you talking about?
Use it!
Four!
That's it?
Oh.
What the hell?
That one was way less dramatic than, uh, the DARPA chiefs.
The DARPA chief was crawling all over us.
Um...
Colonel, are you listening?
Now he's dead.
Yeah, Colonel.
I have no idea.
Don't lie to me.
Well, there are lots of drugs that can cause a heart attack
in large doses.
I have no idea, Snake.
But we won't be able to tell without doing an autopsy.
Snake, I want you and Merrill to work together.
Can I trust her?
More than you can trust me.
Get in contact with her.
electrical interference coming from there it should be okay
if you do burst transmission like us but normal transmission
is probably impossible try moving away from that area okay
snake get a hold of yourself Naomi what the hell is the
better all-american reject song you could tell because it
was like no is that the one that are you sure yes we have no
one like that in our unit is that the song snake I'm
counting on you I'm counting on you all right we need to get
her stuff from the back of the box um let's call some people
real quick such as a mailing let's save i gotta go to the
bathroom so bad you can't use your radar in that area
there's yeah yeah yeah save yes exactly yeah uh memory card
a i'll just do new file yes I've had too much coffee!
Be careful, Snake.
Come on, Maling, tell me, tell me one of your stories!
Call Campbell too.
The DARPA chief and President Baker.
So now the terrorists know both detonation codes.
This sucks.
Yeah, and on top of that, they both died right in front of
my eyes.
Oh, please!
I guess...
I didn't have to start this up.
I guess I could have gone to the bathroom.
I gotta go to the bathroom.
Okay.
Or...
Find the Metal Gear Chief Engineer that President Baker
mentioned.
Hal Emmerich.
Ugh.
In any case, you should contact Merrill by Kodak.
Wasn't her frequency written on the back of the package?
Yes.
Oh, thank you.
Okay, I'll be right back.
I'll be right back.
I gotta go to the little ghosties room.
BRB.
I'm back.
I am back!
Thank you!
For the...
Super Chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you guys, thank you.
Oh my gosh, you guys!
Welcome back!
Tadaiima!
Tadaiima, Tadaiima, Tadaiima!
Alright, as one must do...
as one must do when in this moment one must look at the back
of the box
which i have right next to me we must look at the back of
the box everybody so let's pull that up so we can get
merrill's codec
it's written for ants I can't read it It's so small
Okay well I can't read it Well we know what it says anyway
Okay Oh but we can't even do it here So let's uh
Okay um
Oh there's bullets and stuff there too Hello, mister.
Do we have clearance too now?
I don't remember.
Oh, yes, we do.
Grab that.
Oh, never mind.
We didn't even use that many bullets.
Ah, ah.
Wait, what is this place?
What is this place?
Oh, the armory.
Oh, this is the...
Oh, now the people are here okay um but we gotta go oh well
i guess uh okay was that door always there was that door
always there not the size of the codec but how you use it
right of course of course we there's no reason for us to go
in here yet i don't think um okay let's go I'm just going to
go this way because but well the guys are going to like walk
down the way let's get our M, hello, M 9 controller,
controller, there we go okay we got to go to the um nuclear
warheads building for our little buddy yes, even in the
original That door wasn't available in the OG game with your
card key at the time.
Oh, okay.
That's probably why.
It's originally like level six.
Oh, that's so interesting.
All right, don't be a baby.
I'm a little scared, though.
Because what if they see me?
Uh, where is the trap?
Oh, the trap is already activated.
Nice.
Okay.
Uh, uh, uh, there.
Come on, please, Snake, turn around!
Press the button!
Drop him in the hole!
That's so rude!
I don't, uh, I don't remember if there's any level twos in
here, but we got, we'll come back anyway, so...
Doesn't really matter, I think.
Uh, well, press...
Uh...
One.
Oh, that was close.
He was coming right up by us.
Famous!
It's okay, we'll come back.
Famous is level two.
Why is it like...
Oh!
That was so close.
You little jerk.
I saw him back there.
Hmm.
Where are you?
Oh, hello.
Hello.
That's one down.
Hmm.
next one is uh actually i don't know where he's next one is
uh thank you soup um the music in this part is so lame oh
dang it it's so not good as the original they get rid of the
chorus and it's just so oh hello to you hello hello Hello!
It's just not as nice.
Where the heck is this other guy?
Not the status reports!
You're killing me!
Oh gosh, no.
Please, no.
No, they don't, we don't need the backup unit!
Oh, is there a...
No.
Yes!
Ugh!
It feels so good.
Status report.
It's the bane of my existence, for real.
The status report will actually kill me, I think.
Just imagining things.
Just imagining.
Oh.
They're not gonna come up here, are they?
Oh shoot, they're right here!
Ah!
Um, hold on.
Um...
Hmm...
I didn't realize they were on the second floor.
How do I want to handle this?
How do we want to
handle this?
I thought they were down below.
I didn't know they were
up.
You didn't see them on your radar?
No, they weren't on the radar.
Can
I get up, please?
Also, can we attach my rations?
Thank you.
And, uh...
Oh.
Uh.
Oh, please.
Please.
Game!
You piece of shit!
Shut up!
Oh, oh.
And, uh, I'm bleeding out.
But you will be too.
soon uh can you like not run towards me stressing me out i
underestimated oh my god ow can you calm down
clear clear
clear clear move
clear no stop no no
Don't keep going.
Get up, Stag!
Oh wait.
My cardboard box!
How could you?
Ah, la la la.
Do you think I can get him?
There we go.
Stop, please stop coming!
Why are you homing?
At who?
At what?
Who are you homing at?
Hmm?
Clear!
Get out of here.
I think I just...
Um, maybe ruin my chances of getting away with that.
All good!
Return to your positions, everybody.
Return to your positions.
If I knock this guy out, though, they're just going to cause
another status report issue thing, isn't it?
Stop
moving.
Actually, can you not make some noise?
Can you, like...
Are they
coming up?
Can't tell.
Are they going to come up?
Hmm.
I'm actually not sure.
I don't think so.
Lockers?
Oh, you're right.
Actually, that might be even better.
Oh.
I don't see anyone on the radar, so maybe it's okay.
B, B is to attack.
Baby.
Baby, baby, baby.
Wait.
Oh.
I think we're good, maybe.
The camera is so fast.
Oh.
Did I go?
What?
No!
Please!
I didn't!
I didn't pay too!
Save.
Oh, safe.
No, it was so fast.
La, la, la.
La.
This goes back outside, doesn't it?
Uh-oh.
I don't want to shoot the cams yet until we get the
suppressor for the, uh, for the SOCOM.
Just imagining things.
imagining things.
So true.
Just imagining things.
Is there any way to get down from here or does this just go
outside?
I don't want to go outside yet or again.
It's so bright out.
Is there anything in here?
Hmm.
Hello.
Is there any items though?
Nope.
Okay.
All the way back.
Maybe the...
Maybe they don't know where I am.
Maybe it got rid of the alert.
Right?
Yeah.
Yeah, it just got rid of it probably.
Nothing here.
Oh, see?
right but that guy who was asleep he's gonna be my biggest
worry because we're gonna not know if he is staring at us or
not we're not he's probably awake now
okay and the camera
um what's our best What's our best call to action here?
Oh, I can hear him.
Can I get him from here?
Oh, I missed my shot.
I wonder, though.
Maybe wait, hold on.
I'm going to...
Oh, wait.
If I press A, it doesn't come out.
oh oh oh we can't get we can't get low enough that's a shame
that's a shame that is a darn shame okay i'm gonna wait for
him to come all the way back we're gonna have to be fast
actually i have another idea
i have another idea wait a second get to Huey.
We go through... We go to... Yes, I know where to go.
Okay.
Yes, yes, yes.
Um... Is he walking away?
I think we're good.
Can I go down?
Hello?
How do I go down?
Nothing here.
Please don't... Please don't notice me.
Okay, good, good, good, good, good.
Okay, here we go.
This is...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
How do I drop down?
Drop down.
Yeah.
We gotta go through.
Oh,
wrong.
I said it keeps saying Huey!
Oh, no.
My brain is poisoned.
My brain is poisoned, you guys.
No, not Huey.
Shit.
Take him over here.
I'm getting a little bit more used to the controls now.
Yippee!
Thank you, sir!
Okay.
Where's our other friend at?
I'm not gonna get that guy because he scares me.
What?
Just run.
Oh, it's this guy.
I forgot about him.
Oh shit!
Oh gosh!
Never mind.
Um...
We're okay!
Everything's good!
How do I attach the suppressor?
Get out of here, Huey.
SMH.
Truth.
Resp-on.
Oh, here.
Uh, equip.
equip with you.
Attach!
Yippee!
Now we can kill!
Without...
Without worry!
Thank you.
They're not gonna come in here.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
I think I think I'm getting a sense of deja vu in here I
think I'm receiving oh a weird strange what is this sense of
oh like I've oh oh my brain brain hurts it's like I've lived
through this before oh my gosh okay attach the rations no oh
okay you're you're You just, where are you?
Oh, oh!
Acknowledge what, huh?
That I'm too strong for you!
Okay.
Um, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma, ma.
Hmm.
I know they're gonna come in here, and they're gonna see my
box, and they're gonna come after me, they're gonna see my
box!
Why don't you go after your dead friends first?
Level a million IQ, everybody.
Excuse me.
I'm trying to call.
Thank you.
In any case, you should contact Merrill by codec.
Wasn't her frequency.
I forgot this whole time that we haven't called Merrill yet.
Oh my gosh.
I forgot this.
I was just like, Merrill, when are you going to open the
door for us to go?
We haven't even contacted her.
Oh, I'm...
Oh, no.
I forgot this whole time who's are you I was really
impressed like what oh and are you gonna open the door for
us to go prison you're the Colonel's niece Merrill right
mm-hmm no it's not him mm-hmm just exactly who are you hmm
snake I'm the fool that your uncle sent to this hellhole you
came alone you are so silly I don't need lectures you're
just like your uncle You know, I didn't know my uncle.
We go way back.
I know What's your name?
My name is not important.
Aha.
Could you be snake?
Are you solid snake?
Who's asking?
The legendary solid snake?
You?
Yeah, I'm a little legendary.
Sorry about before.
I wasn't sure if you were one of the good guys.
But I knew you were.
How?
It's your eyes.
My eyes?
they're rookies eyes right no they're beautiful and
compassionate eyes just what I'd expect from the legendary
solid snake I'm trying to sweep me off my feet Wow don't
worry you'll land back on them once you meet me the reality
is no match for the legend I'm afraid I have more confidence
now why did you look so surprised when you saw my face the
reason just like him you mean the terrorist leader liquid
snake liquid yeah you know him you're not are you I have no
family so what's the deal then I don't know I killed my dad
maybe I'll ask him personally but first I miss womanizing
snake you were involved in this exercise from the beginning
what exactly happened here I just joined the training that
same day that's okay but what is this place I don't think
it's just a nuclear weapon disposal facility yeah it's a
little weird it's just like them nobody's told you anything
did they nope okay you see this place isn't really for
disposing nuclear weapons this base is owned and operated by
a dummy corporation of arms tech this is a civilian base
right for the development of metal gear Colonel Foxhound and
the next generation special forces trying to get home called
here for the test launch actually I think I have a pizza on
the head I was gonna have it yesterday but because pizza you
read my mind they figured they could help keep it all hush
but they must have been test firing dummy warheads for a
while why just this time I heard it was making me a little
shaky test before the formal adoption of the metal gear
program so I have to go start that's what I heard anyway
when I went to the bathroom I should have started the oven
sounds kind of fishy so what do you think the terrorists
want sorry I'm not sure I was captured with President Baker
right after the revolt started damn oh yeah that's when he
gave you the detonation calorie made right that's right
amazing articulated python well women have more hiding
places than men more anyway you met girly huh how's he
holding up girly he's dead what heart attack what do you
mean the chief the chief died from a heart attack too yeah
was either them sick or anything no not that i heard of you
know first time i get it but second time it's a little
suspicious something funny is going on Huh, sounds like it.
But I have no idea what.
Me neither.
Dinner.
Diazepam and cigarettes.
Do you know the person who designed Metal Gear?
You mean Dr. Emmerich?
How?
He should be in the research lab.
Not Huey.
I can't believe I kept saying Huey.
Second floor basement.
Yeah.
That's where his lab is.
I think they're forcing him to work on the nuclear launching
program.
So they'll need him alive until that's done anyway.
Thank you.
Then we'd better do something before.
Going to the bathroom is important since you never know when
a long cutscene will begin.
I need to ask him how to destroy Metal Gear.
You plan to take that thing on by yourself, Snake?
Oh yeah.
It won't be the first time.
Woo!
It's so cool!
How do we get to the nuclear warhead storage where the
doctor's being held?
There's a cargo door on the first floor of this building
that leads to the north.
What's the security level of the door there?
Five.
Five!
It's okay.
I've got a level five.
Oh.
I've got to go save the doctor.
You should go to the I'm going with you.
No, you're just gonna get my way You're still too green.
I want you to hide somewhere.
I told you to be a good girl.
Oh, yes, you are You pause for just one second in front of
your enemy and it's all over.
No, I'm still green too Good luck doesn't last forever five.
I don't know what happened.
I just couldn't pull the trigger right away sad music I
never had any problems in training
take someone's life it's not like shooting targets and
training what is this music I always dreamed of being a
soldier every day of my life I've trained my mind and body
for the one day when I could finally see some real action
and now oh this is different you want to quit I can't quit I
can't allow myself to quit now listen you're not normal if
you don't feel something the first time you kill I don't
hate it but killing without guilt produces more carnage In a
war, you'll get used to it.
All of mankind's worst emotions, worst traits emerge.
It's easy to forget what a sin is in the middle of a
battlefield.
But this isn't a war.
It's a terrorist action.
You're just a little jumpy from the combat high.
The adrenaline in your bloodstream is starting to thin out.
Just take it easy.
But I learned all about combat high at the academy.
We'll talk about it later.
For now, just think about keeping yourself alive.
Can you open the door for me?
I think of a trouble.
alive i'll think about that other stuff i need to get the
hall okay let me try to say this another way stay the hell
out of my way stay the hell out of my way just like my uncle
said i told you the real me is no match for what if i just
hide under the looks like you were a tank until okay snake
i'll be a good girl we'll link up after i grab the doctor
hang on to the key until then um got you but listen i know
this area better than you call me if you have any questions
be careful okay i love the awkward laugh together wait
you're upstream thank you your influence made me buy the
metal gear collection on switch for my birthday woohoo have
fun with it um i have to leave first.
Get the FAMIS?
Yeah, we'll go back to the armory and go get it.
You know what?
Because we're right here by the...
I'm in caution anyway, so it's probably...
Come on, please!
Please, please!
No, God!
Please, please, please.
No one.
Just press the button.
Press the button!
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Please, please, please, please.
Oh, God.
They're both coming.
Ah, easy.
Which, uh, does it be?
Two.
Oh, oh.
Who's there?
No one.
Who's that?
Oh, um.
It's the enemy.
I need- It is?
Oh, come on!
Let me just get that gun!
Um, I'll go in blasting.
I don't like the alert oh my gosh there's a ton of you get
out of my way get out of my way out of my way What the
What what
What yo Is this a trap?
I think this one's a trap This one we need the cigarettes
for yeah Are they
gonna come in here?
That was so close!
They won't come in here because what are they gonna do?
Pass through the lasers?
They can't.
What?
Who just died?
Um.
Huh?
Just died.
He fell into the trap hole!
No way.
It's gonna run out and they're gonna leave.
Okay.
He just does that.
I almost pressed the wrong button.
I almost pressed A when I had it equipped.
Press Y button for safety?
What do you mean?
Wait, I can turn the safety on?
Probably should save.
You are so right.
Can you call it fake?
It's the one, it's the theme they don't use anymore.
Save complete.
Okay.
Come on, Melein, give me that.
Snake, in China they say you must cross the river before you
tell the crocodile he has bad...
Oh, let's also call the colonel since we got a Meryl.
It means that the wise man avoids danger first.
Use your brain to avoid traps.
And stay away from the enemy.
Avoid the traps.
I got you, girl.
I was so smart before.
I had copyright issues, right?
Yeah, it was very similar.
Wait, no!
Colonel, your nephew!
Your nephew.
Neese.
Your niece!
Yeah, it was very similar to a Russian composed song.
so unfortunately it had to be um had to could not use it
anymore so sad oh there's the hole that is oh i thought that
was a hole again oh my god oh my god oh my god
don't see me but i am gonna just gonna there you go sleep
tight
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go back, come back, come back,
come back, please, please.
Wait, Minty, reheat your pizza in the oven?
No, it's, um...
Snake, I unlocked the cargo door for you.
It's, uh, it's one of those, like, oven pizzas.
Where I can see ya?
Don't move around too much.
Ghost Mid finally awakes.
Praise Smash Ball, thank you for the super die!
What does that mean?
It's been nine years.
Nothing.
Listen, Snake.
The cargo door is like an airlock.
It's equipped with infrared sensors.
Be careful.
Wait, where is the...
If an intruder is sensed, gas is released.
Gas.
Okay, so we'll meet at the nuclear warhead storage building.
I thought you said you'd be a good girl.
I changed my mind.
Don't get careless.
That's when things always turn sour.
You said you'd be a good girl.
Sorry.
but this is the only way I can figure whether or not I'm cut
out to be a soldier um I gotta get my hands dirty actually
where can I get the thermal goggles yet get yourself killed
because the one room had the suppressor and the other
had wait
be careful snake that airlock is set with infrared sensors
what is it what is it you probably can't see them with your
naked eyes but there are infrared beams coming out of that
wall.
Touch any one of them and the doors will seal off and the
place will be flooded with poison gas.
Somehow you've got to get through without setting off those
sensors.
I'm gonna die from the cigarettes!
Cigarettes are gonna kill me.
Uh, okay.
Okay, this one's slow.
Don't see me in here.
Oh, it's really...
Okay.
Nothing here.
Yep, nothing here.
Nice and easy.
I wonder if I should use one.
What is Mint's alignment?
Good girl?
Bad girl?
Neutral girl?
Hmm.
I think I was a good girl, but I changed my mind.
I think I will use it just in case, though.
We're about to go into another fight.
So we'll get some more rations.
Uh, okay.
Okay, that one is down.
It's really slow.
So now probably is...
Okay, it's going back up.
It's so slow.
This one's not so bad.
Yippee!
I'm gonna bad girl.
I changed my mind.
I'm a bad girl now.
Good thing we got the grenades.
Be careful.
There are claymore mines around there.
Who are you?
Who is this?
Just call me Deep Throat.
Deep Throat.
The informant from the Watergate scandal.
about that you're not using burst transmission are you
nearby listen there's a tank in front of your position
waiting to ambush you what are you anyway one of your fans
me you're one of my fans huh um i am gonna save too and
let's let's actually call campbell too because we didn't do
that yet colonel i got a codec oh we missed the one i guess
about maryl my bad i know we were Mailing knows everything
about the communication system.
He's a wisp.
It's part of the fandom.
Well, if somebody knows your frequency, they can call you.
But the question is, how did he learn it?
It's top-secret information.
So you mean someone leaked the information?
And that's the only explanation I can think of.
Who's got my number?
Do you know where that transmission originated from?
Why are you so quiet all of a sudden?
I'm sorry.
The radio waves were too weak to locate their source, but
I'm sure he's near you.
Snake, you'll have to go through the minefield to advance.
Okay.
Um...
Hey, Master Miller.
Master, does the name Deep Throat mean anything to you?
Deep Throat?
What?
You mean the guy from Watergate?
No.
But he uses the same name.
How do you know, Snake?
You don't know?
You don't know if it's the same guy from Watergate?
You can't say for sure.
You don't even know who he is.
He wasn't using burst transmission.
he was transmitting from somewhere on this base somewhere on
the base yes I have no idea master Miller is very intrigued
in this information he's like who else is on the base hey
Merrill do you know a deep throat sounds like his mind
sounds like harassment if I ask her you'll be able to see
the minds displayed on your hey Merrill do you know deep
throat oh we didn't even ask her okay we
Some class.
After you locate the mines on your radar, crawl forward and
retrieve them.
Oh, I'm gonna crawl forward and retrieve them.
Anti-personnel mines have killed over 20,000 non-combatants
in the past 30 years.
Is that real?
In countries like Cambodia and Nicaragua, the killing and
maiming of innocent victims continues long after the war has
ended.
It is easy to plant the mines, you see.
But removing them is a different matter.
She's out.
It requires more time and manpower.
She was like, oh, she didn't even let us ask.
She was like, By the way, bombs.
The superpowers need to donate more mine detectors and other
equipment to remove them.
It is the least we could do after laying them.
People still find, like, grenades and stuff to this day,
which is insane to me.
Pick up.
If you're one of my fans, isn't it an honor to have me call
you?
Wouldn't you be like, wow!
A minefield, huh?
Don't forget to use your mine detector.
I got it.
When you find out where a mine is, crawl forward and try to
recover it.
In this game, does it matter which way I crawl towards it?
Does it have...
Do I have to...
Okay.
Do I have to crawl from behind?
What can I do for you, Snake?
I'm just saving.
You know.
Don't forget to save.
Too shy to pick up.
Wow, the save is so fast.
How's it going, Snake?
Have you gotten used to the radar yet?
I'm getting there.
Imagine if Master Mellet answered, who told you that code
name?
Pretty convenient, huh?
It also makes it easy for us to see everything that you're
doing.
You're watching everything?
Of course.
If you were my boyfriend, you'd never be able to cheat on
me.
Oh!
Being monitored 24 hours a day, that'd be like hell.
Don't think of it like that.
At least you'd never get lost.
Snake does not like being...
watched i'll tell you years ago when i was in another unit
my unit's morale was at an all-time low it was up to me to
boost their morale somehow what do you mean by that what
what what what what do you what do you what do you mean by
that customer johnson what do you mean by that
is the mine oh the mindy oh holy cow that was so close
Nope, turn around.
Just like that.
Be a good girl.
And then I can get up.
And we can go this way.
I don't...
I'm too scared to know if I have to...
If I have to approach him from behind or not.
You know what I mean?
Spin.
But I guess, maybe not.
Because I can get...
These ones?
Or...
Uh...
Just go, just get them?
I'm afraid of triggering the cutscene.
Ooh.
That doesn't matter in the first game.
So, maybe it's fine.
They will not go off?
Okay.
I'm trusting you guys.
That's so evil.
Okay.
That was scary.
That was so scary.
All right.
No more mind detector.
I think we're good.
Clip our rations.
Okay.
How to use the grenades.
Press a button to hold, release to throw.
How long button is pressed?
varies the distance and we got a couple chaff grenades not a
lot just a few but it should be enough to maybe get him
stunned a couple times oh when did we get magazines mint
boss i discovered you by metal gear when you were in heaven
over a year ago and became a fan i discovered a long term
health issue and had a rough time your positivity and metal
gear brain right help save save my life oh my gosh george
I'm glad that, or rather I hope you're doing better now, and
I hope that, um, or I'm glad that, uh, I was able to help
out even if just a little bit.
Okay.
I don't remember how to do this fight.
Like, I remember and I don't remember at the same time.
Oh my gosh, we're gonna see Vulcan Raven for the first time
though.
This is so exciting.
Come on out, buddy.
Like, you use the chaff to distract them, and then you throw
the grenade...
Oh, my ears.
You throw the grenade inside.
All right.
Average beat to burn doyer.
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Uh, my D.
Wow!
Oh!
This is Raven's territory.
Oh, he's gonna say it!
Snakes don't belong in Alaska!
I will not let you pass.
He doesn't sound as cool.
Yeah!
Snakes don't belong in Alaska.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Snake, don't just stand there.
Send him a message.
The bird.
Go, bird, go!
Ah!
Snake, what is wrong with you?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh my god, Snake, what's wrong with you?
That's right, you belong on the ground.
Oh, I see, I hear it now, I hear it more now.
You belong on the ground.
I'm like a slithery snake.
A little snake.
You should crawl on the ground like the snake you are.
You are.
Come, let's fight.
Don't forget to shut it!
Yeah, don't forget to shut it, buddy.
Okay, um, let me also...
Wait, um, chaff grenades, press A to aim, release, to throw.
Okay, so we gotta get pretty close so we can, um...
We only have six though.
Okay, remember to punch the tank.
Can I actually?
Oh my god.
Oh!
Wait!
Wait, why is there a...
He came out to laugh at me.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, I wish I could cartwheel right now.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm just gonna throw the chap grenade.
Oh gosh, please!
Did I go?
I don't know if I...
Okay, I threw it.
Nice.
I'm dying.
Ouch.
I don't know where I threw it.
it you don't do not do not do not oh my god snake where did
he go okay oh oh gosh I'm stuck inside the hole why oh no
he's gonna run me over he's gonna run me why did you throw
it that way get that guy there we go yeah yeah there we go
there we go and
nice I think actually I'm not sure actually
I don't know if that worked
come here gunner one oh
nice nice
Oh god, please, snake, please.
Oh my god, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no.
Lowey!
Oh my god, snake, please!
Oh, that did not work.
See how you like this!
Oh, gunner two!
Oh, I pressed it, but it didn't work.
Okay, that's fine.
I don't think it registered because he was loading.
Ah!
It lands right in his lap.
It's so funny.
He's like holding on to it.
Oh, we have to wait for him to come back up.
Okay, there we go.
All right, come back, mister.
Don't run me over.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, gosh.
We only have one ration left.
Oh my god, get up, Snake.
Okay, I'm gonna chaff grenade real quick so that we can,
um...
Oh my gosh, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh
my god.
Where's some rations?
Please, please rations.
Oh no, no, no, there's no rations!
Oh no, there's no rations.
Okay, that's not good.
Uh...
I know I might be wasting them, but I don't want them to get
me with the...
I'm about dead.
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die for real!
Where are the rations?
I'm gonna die!
If he gets me one more time, I'm dead.
Boo!
I can't- Oh.
Uh, yeah, that's fine, actually.
So unfair.
This is so unfair!
Oh, that was a nice hit.
Oh, dang it, he's not there yet.
There are no rations.
I'm going to die again, please.
So unfair.
This is so unfair.
Don't get me.
Don't.
Oh, my God.
Oh, there.
There he is.
Nice, nice, nice.
We were so close.
Last time I did that fight.
I don't want to brag, but I did it in one try.
Chew.
That was too early.
There's nothing!
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
You wasted all the time laughing at me!
This is so unfair.
That's so unfair!
I can't believe!
That is so unfair.
No way.
Okay, well, I'm here now, I guess.
Oh, my god.
That's right.
And then he goes inside for a second.
Come back out.
Oh, wait.
I'm going to lose my health.
Oh, my God.
Don't run me over.
You know what?
It's fine.
Wait.
Did he go back in?
You son of a jerk.
You poopy hulk.
Yeah, let it.
I just ran right into that.
There we go.
Oh, no.
When I got shot, it...
Oh my gosh, the way it lands in his lap is so funny.
When I got shot, it made me drop my grenade.
That's so messed up.
Nope, that's the wrong way.
That's the wrong way.
Ah.
Nah, nah, nah, waiting for my help.
Don't shoot me, please.
This is so...
Oh!
No!
Gotta fix my contact.
Thank you, Earl.
The voice is the same as Robin from Teen Titans.
No way!
Really?
Oh my god, he's gonna rip!
Oh, no, no, no, get up, get up, get up, get up!
Why did you turn around?
This is...
I missoscelot fight.
The way it lands in his lap.
He's down, but also so are we, basically.
We are so not looking good.
Why are there...
It does sound like Robin!
It is Robin!
Um...
Still got two rations.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
It's okay, though.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
I dropped it.
Shoot.
This way.
Don't run over me.
Why is this fight so stupid?
Please, Snake, just throw it in there.
No!
There we go.
Yes, yes, yes.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There we go.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna...
Oh no!
I dropped the grenade again.
Let's go get some more.
Um...
More grenade, please.
Thank you.
Where are you?
Where's...
You think it would be easier finding a tank?
Oh!
Golly!
Whoa, Moli!
And shoot!
Oh my god.
Oh, this hurts so much.
No, what?
That didn't get in him?
Someone said to crawl in here.
What happens if I do?
Is there another...
There's just ammo in here.
There's no...
There's no ration in here.
There's only ammo in here.
You're not supposed to get run over by the tank.
Oh, oh, ah.
Aren't you supposed to run out of bullets at some point?
I pressed A.
Please.
Ha!
Why didn't that work?
No, Snake, please.
Why?!
What are these cutscenes?
Snake, answer me!
What are these cutscenes that are killing me?
Snake!
I don't understand!
I keep thinking that the cutscene means that it's like
hitting him, but it's not!
I don't understand!
Oh my goodness!
I wish there was some more does the stun grenade help so
much I see that they're suggesting it why don't they give
any rations though the game says get good truly the game
just says get good loser oh oh I hate this I I why do you
Show me that.
He's, oh, there it is, there it is, there it is.
In his little lap.
But it showed it in his lap.
Get up.
Or just get hit immediately again.
That's okay too.
Shoot!
Right there, no!
Oh!
Now it worked!
Yay!
Why are you saying mint?
Dot dot dot!
What do you mean?
The cutscene you keep seeing is when a grenade destroys a
tank tread.
Ah!
There's so many ways to do this, but she's stubborn.
Hey, this is the way that I've always done, you know?
And yeah, I am stubborn.
What of it?
what
oh he's doing sick wheelies okay get up get out
you know what that's how every Metal Gear game is actually
there's oh my god no please oh but okay okay I see it I get
it now it kind of makes it so it oh shit no no no no no no
no it does makes it so it's harder for it to move I get it
what Where did that come from?!
It just completely rolled!
Oh.
Punch the tank.
Okay, I'll punch the tank.
I did so well every time I fought this dang thing in the
original.
I truly...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm only gonna... I'm just gonna say...
I'm gonna... I'm gonna chalk it up to performance anxiety.
That's all I can say.
That's all I can, you know, I can believe in what really...
Oh my god.
Maybe because I'm playing it the way that I have been in...
What's it called?
In the original?
But, like, this is still so similar, so it's, you know.
Just CQC it.
Does that actually work?
I can't tell if you guys are trolling me.
Where'd you go?
Right in his lap.
I like Santa Claus.
We're only on Gunner 1.
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
Oh gosh.
Round 2.
Come on, Gunner 2.
Thanks, Robin.
That did big damage.
I might get the...
No.
Nice.
Can you move?
Stop capping me, my hands are obsessed with me.
Stop capping me.
Okay, we're going.
Uh, up, up, up.
Go, go, go.
Run, run, run.
Oh, I only have four grenades left.
Please.
Nice.
I
need more grenades.
Don't fall them No, not trap grenades Regular grenades Oh,
grenade Grenade I need more grenade, grenade There we go
Santa Claus Wait, is it gonna explode?
Did it already explode?
Oh Oh Oh Oh
Okay, I'm gonna go punch the tank.
I'll punch the tank.
You guys want me to punch the tank.
I'll go punch the tank CQC to flip the tank.
I would believe it in this game truly
He's so oh my god, he's aiming right at me.
It's so funny.
Okay, beat up the tank Oh Ouch you guys it didn't work It
didn't!
You guys...
It didn't work!
Hold on, my chat froze.
Oh, my tap just crashed.
No, I'll just do this.
Give me a second.
I almost died!
You guys, how could you lie to me?
How could you do that?
How could you lie to me?
You see QC in the chat instead?
Okay, I think we're good.
Where is he?
Hold on, I'm going to go this way.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
There it is.
No, no, no.
Hold on.
Don't camp me.
Let me get out of here first.
Okay, we're so close.
We just got to do it.
We just got to beat him.
Up and away.
I'm sorry you're wrong.
Why are you...
It's gonna explode, Snake!
It's gonna explode!
No way, he's walking.
Yo!
Oh my god, what a dummy.
Oh, nice.
Number three.
Wow.
Wait, Vulcan Raven- Boss, is this all right?
Just giving him the card like that.
How are you still alive?
You would be wise not to underestimate him.
What did you think of him?
He is just as you said.
A buffoon.
He lives and breathes combat.
Just like you, I would expect no less from your...
You see, I told you so, but I will kill him.
From your what?
General Ivan, I hear that you lost your arm and ran away
home.
Watch your tongue, Shaman.
Thank you!
In the language of the Sioux people, Sioux means snake.
Snake.
It is known as an animal to be feared.
Well, snake is mine now.
When I meet him next, I'll take special...
kill him oh yes you will oh never mind he and i will meet
again in battle yes we will yes the raven on my head it
thirsts for his blood
oh yeah i love hulk and raven he's so cool God.
Wait, can I go back out?
I kind of want to get some more stuff.
Wait, are the cameras going to be here, though?
Actually, I don't remember.
When did the camera show up?
Not quite yet.
Cool.
But, are there mines?
I don't think so.
Grenade.
Anything out?
That guy didn't even leave anything either.
Chaffs.
Which we will need lots and lots of later on.
Oh!
This is all back too.
Nice.
Grenade.
Doesn't hurt to stock back up on some things.
Right!
Is there anything under the tank?
Can we even go under the tank?
Spin!
Nope.
I need goodies.
Things for me to collect.
Anything that I missed out on?
I don't think so.
Mei Ling would tell me that I am a fool right now.
Oh!
Was that there the whole time?
But I did so well in that last one.
We have five out of five.
I didn't even use any.
So take that game.
him.
Speaking of, mailing.
Let's save.
Who is it, Snake?
Save.
Thank you!
Just giving him the card like that, implying Robin flying
out to the tank and landing in front of Snake was plaid.
I don't know.
Right?
We'll save complete.
There we go.
Snake, have you ever heard this saying, friendly counsel
cuts off many foes?
No.
It means that a little bit of advice from friends can save
you a lot of trouble.
You should think about it.
If you're in trouble or if you need some information about
something, please contact Colonel Campbell or someone else,
okay?
Yeah, thank you.
Oh, okay.
That is so, oh my gosh, it's so true.
Last night, I don't know.
Like recently, well, I don't know.
Ever since I came back, I've been feeling like kind of a
little overwhelmed.
I feel like I'm kind of like a little...
there's just been a lot going on that i'm like oh my gosh i
don't know i don't know i don't know what i'm doing
essentially i've been kind of feeling like super not rusty
it's just that you know when i was when i was streaming
before i um you know i was teeny tiny and then in heaven I
had a lot of stuff handled for me and then I came back and
there's like you know like things that I'm just like I don't
know how to handle some of this stuff and so last night I
like talked with Matara for like maybe two hours I was just
like are you free because um I've just been feeling like it
was like we talked until like 2 a.m.
or something I was like I'm feeling I need I need your
advice I'm so overwhelmed and I was like I was like crying
I'm just like so just like so I don't know what I'm doing
but she gave me some good advice good to help good stuff
good good to help me and like I've been talking with some
other people too just about I don't know sorry that like
really resonated with me for some reason thanks Mei Ling
you're a real one you're a real one Mei Ling wait there
wasn't anything in here either was there unless it respawned
oh oh oh there is nothing behind me yeah
thanks mailing yeah it's real advice oh oh there we go nice
okay i think i got everything from this area for now yeah
but yeah it's just been hasn't been easy because I'm, yeah
like I said like but it's, you know, it's fine I'm just
feeling all sorts of things feeling all sorts of ways let's
get our ration
oh never mine we don't need it i'm too good wow this is so
cool look at them going
literally growing pains yeah a little maybe um let's see we
don't need our mind detector anymore i'm gonna put our
rations oh wait we can't shoot in here wait we can put them
to oh
No!
I was gonna say we can use our M9, but we can't use that in
either.
Okay, never mind.
The game, before it lets you at least try, but now it's
like, um, don't even think about it.
Missy.
Trying on hearing your plays.
Good for the soul.
You're doing so well, keep it up.
Thanks, Conqueror.
I'm not doing that well, but it's okay.
I'm having fun.
What are you talking about?
It is interesting.
Oh, that's where they keep the nuclear warheads.
Can't you see them?
No, I'm...
Yeah, there's lots of boxes piled up in here, but...
Why are there just warheads in boxes?
They're all dismantled warheads.
They just leave them here?
Yeah!
It's like President Baker said.
Totally careless.
They're working on a limited budget.
They try to put on a pretty face for the media, but this is
the grim reality of it.
Where are my tax dollars going to?
all of the warheads in those boxes have had their detonation
mechanisms removed so there's no fear of them exploding
thank you for the vibe gifted thank you they might leak
plutonium and that would be a serious problem oh snake never
use your weapon on that floor okay well it won't even let me
anyway so you can't catch me using my weapon on this floor
because I'm not allowed because the game what what do you
mean no use What do you mean no use?
It's a box!
Oh, because I'm crouched, I think.
Oh, I was about to say, you...
You can't do this to me.
Ah!
Huh?
Just a box.
He didn't even say anything to me though.
I'm kind of surprised.
I like how she says, you see those boxes?
Actually, I don't.
Actually, I don't see.
I need that guy up there to move.
I need that guy up there to leave.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, lockers.
Okay, um, I think we're not safe.
Okay, thank you.
That's fine.
This is fine.
Uh, yep, this is, okay.
Press the button.
Go, snake, go.
Whoa!
B1.
That was pretty close, wasn't it?
This is not the right floor.
B2.
This is the right floor.
Oh my gosh, you can see him.
He's pacing.
He's a scientist.
You hear me?
Okay, this is where we discover the poison room.
Well, it doesn't look so gassy in there.
Actually, it looks fine.
Actually, it looks totally normal.
Oh, never mind.
Watch out, snake.
The, like, the levels of security here.
First, you gotta make it gassy.
Whoa, whoa.
Oh, yeah!
And then you also have to make it electrified.
It is overkill, absolutely.
Wait.
But, you know...
I guess it's not overkill because I get past it.
Snake, watch out.
That place is filled with gas.
Also, the floor is electrified.
Hey, it's filled with gas.
Also...
The floor will kill you.
I'll destroy the high voltage switch.
It's the switchboard on the northwest wall.
I'll destroy it.
I can't reach it.
Use a remote controlled missile.
Okay.
I'm gonna leave and go back.
Oh.
Going all the way here.
Then to go all the way back.
I'll come back for you, Otacon.
I'll come back for you.
Oh, for anyone curious?
I am going for the Otacon ending this time.
so um because i think it's funnier there's a particular
scene that is that is particularly comical so uh sorry maryl
um but we are going to get oticon ending in this run oh we
got to go all the way back actually i'm going to try and do
the heliport um thingy the heliport what's the word
yes how the thing I'm gonna do that thing the truck ride
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh there's two guys down there though
wait is there two guys oh it's a it's a
I'm gonna hang over the rail and try and fall but i'm
looking at their patterns real quick i don't oh no i think
the camera will see me if i get out of the box won't it i
think it will oh yeah so scary so scary the time this like
so well okay here we go oh please there we go and drop no
Okay, next time.
What's the button to drop?
Maybe it's B.
I don't know it.
Okay.
Try number two.
Okay, we gotta wait for this guy to leave too, I think.
Yeah, he's coming over.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, that...
Okay.
We had it perfect.
If only I didn't mess it up.
What's the button?
Is it B?
I don't know if it's B or X
It's X Thank you Okay X Nice
Thank you guys Otherwise I would have totally pressed B
Time to go
Teleport Is this all there is to load?
how can you not see him it's the mask the mask is you know
not helping them you know i get it to the heliport huh it's
not helping at all i get it i get it he thinks it's full of
junk or something i get it maybe probably okay let's see we
got Guy there, we got the same guys.
No more, no less.
Does he look this way?
No, la la la.
Peep, peep, poop out.
M9 ammo.
Very good.
Which, can I...
Uh...
Uh, I don't think I can reach.
This guy's gonna come back.
Oh, wait.
Well, we want to get this guy over here first, because
otherwise he'll discover his sleeping friend.
Even though if he's sleeping right now, it's no biggie.
So calm to destroy the camera.
Yeah?
Oh, actually, that is a good point.
Once we... Is he coming, or does he not come?
this way actually I don't know let's just put this guy to
sleep the night little baby go to sleep little baby oh
oh there he is oh it's
fine are you dead oh cool I thought
it was gone I thought he was gone he was in fact still there
doesn't matter anyway because
Why would it- why did it go down so quickly before?
That's weird.
Hmm.
Oh god.
Now we...
Are these open?
Nothing here.
Can I shoot from here?
That'd be pretty handy if I could.
If I back up a little.
Oh!
Oh, ho, ho, ho.
Can I get a little closer?
No.
Okay, right here.
Alright.
Come over here.
Where I can see you.
Uh, gotta get your leg.
Mm-hmm.
Just a mosquito.
It happens way more often than you'd imagine.
Those pesky Alaskan mosquitoes, you guys, are so icky.
Did it work?
I think so.
Oh.
He technically did his report.
Oh, maybe he didn't.
Um.
Backup unit.
Oh, there they come.
we can get them too easy peasy one hit them with the old one
two and they will never oh I think they woke them up just
imagining things there's a mosquito it's a really awful
powerful one it sucks all your oh they're searching I think
nothing here nothing here nothing here Where?
I'm hearing so many footsteps.
Oh, I think I'm hearing them above me, maybe?
It sounds so close.
I can't believe there's the...
The one tanker's gone.
It's so funny.
Or the one tank is gone.
Where am I going again?
Oh, the armory.
That's right.
Is that your leg?
Once he's down, we're going to leave.
Actually, I think I can leave now.
But...
We'll just be safe.
Go down.
Go to sleep.
Um...
Okay.
Hmm?
Is there somebody there?
No.
Nobody here.
Nobody.
Nothing here.
Oh, wait!
No, it's B2!
Ah, it's okay.
No word.
Actually...
It's fine.
Nothing here.
We need the Nikita missiles, right?
So stressful.
This guy's gonna come up and discover us.
I do know that.
So we need to act first.
We need to box it up.
Oh my god.
Is he gonna notice me or...
Am I in your way?
Oh, shoot.
Well, that just puts a little damper in our plans now.
Doesn't it?
Um...
Who's that?
Oh, you kicked me before I could grab you!
What is that?
Oh, come on.
It's okay, snake.
All we gotta do is get the Nikita and go.
It doesn't matter.
Oh, wait.
Actually, this might be a good place to hide.
Right?
Because we can just...
They don't like coming in here.
I've noticed.
So, uh...
Good stuff.
Okay, they are right where we need to go.
So you guys need to leave.
That's where the room is.
You're checking?
It's a spooky room.
It is.
I kind of wanted to hear the BDM one, though.
Kind of awesome.
You need to leave!
Actually, I think they do check in here, but...
We'll see if the radar goes down before they get it to this
place.
Yep.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
That guy,
what are you doing?
You're going that way.
Get Nikita first.
Did he hear me in here?
Oh, shit.
Oh, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Where's the box?
Okay.
I think the door's still open.
Okay, no, we're good.
Is there a...
No...
No tricks.
Okay.
And what's in here?
What's this?
Eternal darkness?
Hello?
Okay.
Oh, okay.
All right, now we gotta go back all the way.
Let's wait for him to loop around again.
What if I leave a book?
Leave a sexy book for you to look at.
So you don't come back around.
How do I, how do I plan this?
Press A to set.
Okay.
Over there, you.
Thank you.
you he's just hanging out you know what i gave him a little
present you know now he won't come back okay let's go to
what i gave him a little present now we're we're buds now
we're buddies
do i i hear someone snoring i think
Um...
They turned off the lasers right here, this part.
Right?
Did they turn off the lasers here?
No, they didn't!
That's so evil!
Oh my god, um...
Dying!
Good to check.
When did they turn them off?
Colonel, can you do that for me?
It looks like the infrared sensors that were set up here had
been switched off.
Wait, what?
Am I willing to test it?
Am I...
Um...
Huh?
Why don't I trust that?
I don't...
I'm gonna try.
Because usually they are, right?
In my parents' homeland, they say, if there are more wolves,
the people are eaten.
Oh.
If there are more people, the wolves are eaten.
Who are eating?
Who is...
That means the side with greater numbers is usually the
winner.
Do people eat wolves?
You're sadly outnumbered snake.
Try not to let them see you.
I know.
I know, mailing.
Gaslight 100.
Um...
Oh my god.
I'm gonna run.
I've never seen this cutscene before, though.
Colonel.
Colonel!
Yo, this is so messed up.
I...
Get me out of here!
Might as well give one last read before I die.
Call him?
Yeah, for real.
Colonel, this is your fault.
Snake, it's gas.
Hold your breath.
Your O2 gauge.
Until when?
If you don't breathe, the gauge will decrease.
When it reaches zero, your life gauge will begin to
decrease.
No way.
He just told me to hold my breath.
Meryl.
Deep throat.
No, that's not what I'm asking you.
I see.
Master Miller.
He's trying to help you.
here a trap could be but for the time being i'll have to
trust him
here's to almost two weeks of min's return of mgs stream
develop a kind of sixth sense to warn them of danger trust
your instincts as a soldier as a gamer i love that line so
much um well i guess it's a good thing i saved i i don't
know what a joke what a joke the game told me the sensors
were off the game told me the sensors were off that's so
messed up oh thank goodness okay I wonder though okay hold
on hold on I'm not even gonna look let's let's try calling
Colonel again it looks like the infrared sensors that were
set up here have been switched off yes oh my god I'm so
scared no they have not been turned off colonel is actually
he is actively sabotaging me oh my god oh he is actively
sabotaging me welcome back mint been a while but I kept up
Thank you so much!
Okay.
Oh, dang it, I missed it.
I
think the game is a little bugged.
Respond!
This is messed up.
I think the game is a little bugged.
Is it because I took the... oh.
The heliport way?
Would that affect it?
Fushigi.
Just a game doing a little trolling.
Yeah, because there's also not the cameras set up here and
stuff, so...
Interesting.
I think... Actually, I am gonna use this and we're gonna
grab the ration that's up here.
Colonel's misleading me more than chat does.
Colonel is really trying to make me throw.
Oh.
Actually, this is a good opportunity.
Uh, box.
Oh, wait.
Get up.
And box.
and over here over over here my little safety net my little
safety spot can I see up there I kind of can oh there he is
okay okay I don't know we do know that we can box in front
of the whoa we can box in front of the elevator though so
hopefully as long as I align it right I guess.
Does he stop there?
Yes, he does, but I can go.
Thank you.
Okay, we gotta hurry.
We gotta go, go, go, go, go.
Oh my god, please.
Snake, press the button.
Oh, press the button.
Oh, holy.
Holy cow!
That was close.
B2.
Nothing I see here, nothing to see here.
All good.
It is the Nikita missiles that I need.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, I was about to say, what if I don't even have them?
Okay, Snake, we're gonna need you to hold your breath,
buddy.
It's my first time trying this in this game, so it's gonna
be interesting, to say the least.
Might take a couple tries.
Okay, how do I use this?
A button to aim in first-person view, release the fire, and
control.
Choo!
If you know...
Wait, wait, what are you saying?
Sorry, I'm missing some of your thingies.
Your don't knows.
Oh, wait.
Twin snakes is a ride in VR mission.
The kernel telling you sensors are off might be a glitch in
the matrix.
Mysterious.
Welcome back, Mint.
Metal Gear, Brain Rot is forever.
You have 40 shots, so go for it.
True.
Okay, here we go.
A and release!
Okay, turns.
Ah!
Okay, and nice and neat.
Go, go, go, go, go!
Zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom!
Don't shoot it down, don't shoot it down.
I think I'm a gamer.
Nice, nice, nice.
Now which one has the gas mask?
in it, uh, this one?
No, this one.
That's a dirty magazine.
Wait, a chaff grenade.
I'm just gonna chaff it.
I know I probably shouldn't, but.
Okay, we gotta hurry.
Come on.
It's one of these.
Let's go, go, go, go, go, go.
Grab the book.
Grab the mask.
Put on the mask.
Can I get in this one?
while it's still jammed?
Oh, I can't, I could have, I could have, but it's okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh my gosh, we got that ride and vision real.
Is there a, oh no, there's nothing in here.
Oh wait, there's actually nothing in here.
Okay, there's a node.
Bam, I don't remember if there's anything over here that I
can get, but we'll try.
I don't have much oxygen left.
Come on, let's go.
Nope, not that one.
Yep, this one.
Grenade chaff?
Grenade full?
Oh, shit.
Oh, shoot.
Uh-oh.
Chaff?
Uh-oh, we're in trouble.
Ah!
Just run!
Phew.
There's some more stuff.
Oh, there's chaffs over there.
Oh.
oxygen runs out so fast and that's with the gas mask on
that's with the gas mask on I mean no one comes maybe I
could just bolt through it maybe I could just run really
fast maybe I could just can
you shoot the guns I don't think so because the gas right I
where can I can I can I shoot them down where will I die I'm
scared you can wait no way really where is it oh oh wait
I thought because of the gas it was like gonna appear I
cannot see could have run out of bullets at is right oh i
got him i cannot see what this mask on though oh there's one
oh it's so hard to tell there we go let's go back
hey doof okay and again it's that one right there that's
gonna be tricky this one the one that's pointed straight in
my direction and is not moving could you move a little could
you
okay El Taline oh you're so smart come on come on where is
it Where?
Where is it?
Oh, I got it.
Okay, nice.
So hard to see.
Oh, maybe I should have gotten closer.
Like here, I can...
Uh, maybe not.
Wait, where is it here?
That's it.
You.
Nice.
And...
Uh...
Oh, I can't see it.
Oh, there, there, there.
Got him.
No more Nikita missiles.
Peep-peep.
I think I can make it.
Grab it!
Run, snake, run!
No!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, for real.
No, no, no.
Oh my gosh.
I was right, though.
I knew we'd make it.
Okay.
Um.
Worse?
We wouldn't have died, though.
We wouldn't have died.
It would have been fine.
Okay, let's go see our little buddy.
Our little piss pal.
And one of my favorite scenes of the game.
One of my favorite parts of the game.
Oh, save.
Yeah, I'll say it real quick.
Oh, he's saying the...
Are those the train stations?
Snake, you can't use the radar because something's jamming
it.
Yeah.
And whatever's doing it is very close to you.
Be careful.
I'm careful, I'm careful.
Whoa, it's so...
It's going back and forth between my headphones.
It's so crazy.
Whoa.
be careful snake thanks mailing um colonel i'm scared the
less you maneuver a remote controlled missile the faster it
will fly thanks remember this if you want to fire the
missile over a greater distance awesome thank you also
what's going on snake look at your sea rations they're
frozen you can't use frozen sea rats until they defrost you
won't be able to replenish your energy Wait, why are my
rations frozen?
In a warm place.
Probably just your bare skin would be fine.
My sea rats.
Who says sea rats?
Master Miller?
My sea rats are frozen.
Oh.
Gamer.
The sea rats.
Yo-ho, yo-ho.
The rat life for me.
I'm on the sea.
I am a rat.
I have no business here.
Merrill, are you okay?
Merrill, what are these holes and walls for?
Uh, bullets?
I don't know.
For blowing tiny particles of dust off people's bodies
before they enter the lab.
Oh.
I've never heard that dialogue before.
Nostasha, how you doing?
Good.
You found they so calm.
Yeah, I did.
That's a special operations command pistol.
It's a 45 caliber pistol with plenty of stopping power.
It's also equipped with a lamb from nighttime combat.
I love that artist lamb.
You can equip that too.
That pistol was designed specifically for use by special
forces.
So I think it will be useful.
Some people find it a little heavy in how to use.
Yeah.
But it shouldn't be a problem for you.
Okay.
The voices are a little...
Oh, these holes!
They look like...
They look like dominoes.
all right here we go
i love this scene i hope it's good in this version too we'll
see oh okay this scene is so awesome oh
oh my gosh there's not as much blood so far
Yeah!
Oh!
Wait.
Wait, why did he take off his stealth camera?
Oh my god though, he sliced that guy in half.
No, no, you're supposed to be invisible.
Okay, that's kind of cool though.
No, you're supposed to be invisible though.
Take this!
Robin!
He's alive!
The music.
Caution, stand back.
Because the guy is supposed to be like, it's like he's a
ghost.
I don't know, I don't, I didn't really need to see the whole
scene.
It was so much more mysterious when we didn't see it.
You know?
And then obviously, like, he's supposed to be invisible, and
then like...
The guy's like, it's like he's a ghost.
Oh He's a skewer.
Oh my gosh, the barbecue No, that doesn't make any sense No,
that doesn't make any sense
You can see it.
Wow, he looks so cool though
Ghost Me music is also killing me.
Okay.
This scene was definitely...
I'm...
I'm not a fan.
Actually, I'm... I'm actually quite disappointed.
But that's okay.
That's fine.
I get it.
Not all the scenes are the same.
I got it.
Can I loot their bodies?
You got any rations?
Oh my gosh, I completely forgot that I could get dog tags in
this game.
Okay, time to fight!
Gray Fox.
I don't know.
Oh, my sea rats.
Wait, are they still frozen?
Uh-oh.
I'm gonna start calling them.
Stealth camouflage.
Who are you?
The nipples!
Ow!
On a corner!
Oh, no!
Where is my friend?
It gets me every time.
What are you talking about?
Right behind you.
Whoa!
Oh, what next?
They made him pee twice!
You're that ninja.
I've been waiting for you.
No, no, I don't need...
How did he have war?
Neither enemy nor friend.
Yes!
I am back from a world where such words are made.
Neither enemy nor friend.
Hear that maid.
Now you and I will battle to the death.
What do you want?
Oh, I've waited a long time for this day.
Now I want to enjoy this moment.
I think, uh...
Grey Fox still sounds...
Like I said...
Hold on.
It's like one of my Japanese anime.
Yeah.
I've come from another world to battle with you.
What is it?
Revenge.
Um, because of the voice effects on his, on it, like with
him, it doesn't sound so different, you know?
Maybe because...
Maybe side by side it does, but I think it sounds pretty
good.
He said the thing.
I will kill you, or you will kill me.
B is to punch.
on a con beat the punch you guys be bees to punch all right
then watch from your box seat i need that man hands off him
okay that line i remember i remember how he said it before
and it definitely was better before he's like make me whoa
whoa whoa He's like, make me feel alive again.
Okay, how do I beat him again?
I have to just punch him, right?
Yeah.
And then he does like a...
Whoa!
Oh, I can only get one hit in?
Okay, I'm hearing the differences more now.
I'm hearing the differences in the voice acting more now.
Where are you?
Oh, come here.
Come here.
I can't kick him.
Why can't I kick you?
Oh.
Ah!
No!
I was in mid-attack!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, nice.
There we go.
I don't remember when.
I can.
When can I start using my gun?
I don't remember.
Oh, out.
That'd be so funny if you, I just realized, wait, I need my,
they're still frozen.
Oh gosh, oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Hold on, my sea rats.
My sea rats.
Oh, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Oh, keep, please, Snake.
Oh, when he's, like, in mid-action.
Oh, my God, the GameCube!
There we go.
Nice.
There, there, wow.
And then I have to remember that one last part where he,
like, goes kind of in, right?
Oh, they're better, they're better.
Nice.
Oh, hello?
Invincibility frames?
Excuse me?
Oh my god, that is unfair.
That is unfair.
Excuse me, sir.
I kicked you.
And you...
Oh, oh, I got stuck on the wall.
That's okay.
Okay.
This is...
Don't hurt the GameCube.
Don't hurt Mario!
Why can't I only get one hit in?
Hello.
Whoa, yeah, well...
He's going...
He's going crazy mode.
He's going Insano style.
He's parkouring all over me.
Oh, there we go.
Can you stop doing Cirque du Soleil for two seconds?
Oh my god.
Please.
Nice.
There we go.
Oh.
Hurt me more, Snake.
No, I'm so bad at this part.
Oh, no, wait.
Oh, oh, oh, never mind.
I know exactly where you are.
Hurry up and catch me.
Okay.
Oh, I saw where you went.
Nice.
Oh, uh.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
Yep.
Uh.
Oh.
When can I use my gun?
Oh shit.
Ah!
Uh oh.
Okay.
He do.
Is he gonna come get me?
Run?
Where are you?
Hello?
Hurt me more.
Snake.
Hey!
She said the thing.
Nice.
Yeah, we punched each other in Zanzibar.
Remember...
Oh, dang it.
I remember when I punched you, and you punched me.
Oh, we were punching each other in Zanzibar.
I remember.
Remember that at good times.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
No, no, snake, get up.
Get up, please.
Oh, snake.
Oh, yeah.
It's okay.
He won't see me here.
Just kidding.
Be doop.
Can I like, give me like two seconds, okay?
Great box.
Never mind.
Like two seconds to regain my composure.
Okay, cool.
All right.
The feeling of battle.
So awesome.
Come on, do your little teleporty thing.
Come on, come here.
There we go.
Nice, nice.
Go up a bit.
We got two hits in.
Hurt me more!
Come on, come on, come on!
Oh, out.
All I've been doing is running away.
I still have a lot of rations, so I think we're mostly good,
but at the same time, it's better to be safe than sorry, you
know?
Oh, my god.
That's good, Snake.
Can you, like...
Oh, my God.
Hey dude!
Why is it that every time he punches me?
It, um, makes me like start losing blood.
Hurt me more!
Nice!
Nah, come on here, come on here.
Because of the edge.
I can't even punch well, ninja.
Okay.
Oh,
I totally missed you.
I can't punch well either, apparently.
Oh, his knife hands got it.
I love if I just touch him, it hurts me, though, even.
Hurt me more.
Mew.
Oh,
just a little bit.
Just a little bit more.
Ouch.
I'm trying Stand still I'll hurt you, I'll hurt you Oh, oh
Ouch It's okay Yippee Okay, don't touch him Don't touch him
Wait, yeah, yeah, don't touch him Don't touch him Shoot,
shoot him
Is it gonna go
Oh, oh my god.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ouch.
Oh, oh.
See, this is what we could have been doing the whole time,
but someone had to be like, zippity-doo-doo-doo, all over
the place.
It's also mean.
I was running everywhere, too.
Oh.
This guy was avoiding bullets.
And then...
Wait, wait, where's the last part of the fight?
Where's the last part of the fight?
You're dead?
No, no electrophase?
Say it.
It can't be.
You were killed in Zanzibar.
Zanzibar!
Oh.
Wait, is it here?
No, this happens anyway.
Right?
not again I love how they kept this part even though it was
a dropped subplot oh crazy bang your head on the floor oh my
god great fox no oh my god oh no oh he's crazy what's going
on I'm losing myself.
Aw, gray fox.
Oh.
Are you just gonna...
Are you...
Uh...
Is it over?
Are you just gonna run out?
Um...
The medicine.
Take your meds, everybody.
Snake, this might be a good one.
Good time to move.
Snake, this might be a good...
Why is he always just standing there?
He stood there and got blasted by the tank.
Like...
Colonel, that ninja is Gray Fox.
No doubt about it.
Ridiculous.
He said it.
You yourself in Zanzibar land.
He said, I'm Gray Fox.
He should have been killed, but he's still alive.
What?
It happened before I joined Fox.
What do you know about that, Naomi, huh?
were using a soldier for their gene therapy experiments.
What do you know about that, Naomi?
I never heard that.
It happened right after you retired.
My predecessor, Dr. Clark, was in charge.
Dr. Clark?
Dr. Clark.
He started the gene therapy project.
And where is he now?
Dead.
There was killed in an explosion in his lab two years ago.
So what about this soldier?
Apparently for their test subject, they decided to use the
body of a soldier who was recovered after the fall of
Zanzibar land.
And that was Grey Fox.
but he was already dead yes i miss english naomi here i'll
redo the lines they fed him with a prototype exos while they
experimented on him like plato today's genome soldiers were
born from those experiments that's the sickest thing i've
ever heard i'm sorry colonel i didn't think my accent would
offend you so much because it's confidential information is
that the only reason Naomi, what happened to Gray Fox after
that?
The record said he died in an accident.
I'm sorry.
But even if that ninja is Gray Fox, the question is, he
hated it.
That was Australian?
You're saying he's just living off his will to fight?
I'm not sure, but he seems intent on fighting me to the
death.
We'll meet again.
I know it.
Yeah.
So you'll fight again?
until you kill him.
Shut up, Naomi.
I'd rather not.
But maybe that's what he wants.
That's what he wants.
He said hurt me more.
It was consensual.
Look at the little GameCube.
Oh my gosh.
It's so cute.
It looks just like actually...
Sorry, my GameCube is black.
I was gonna say it looks just like mine.
It is not.
An anime?
No, I'm not.
I always work alone.
Alone?
are you an otaku too come on get out we can't stay here
forever snake in the twin snakes is so mean to Otakon he's
so like in the original he's kind of like he's like soft boy
but in this game he's like he's so mean to him oh so you're
to rescue me my headphones are starting to hurt my ears
there's something that i've got to do first oh oh well at
least you're not one of them
are you hurt
i'm okay i just twisted my ankle a little trying to get away
it's okay my son is used to people being me stop i want to
ask you something i need information about metal Huh?
Metal Gear?
Yeah.
Well, the posters aren't in this one.
Oh, wait.
It's a mobile TMD.
Wait, what is that poster?
It's designed to shoot down nuclear missiles.
It's not police, not.
Only for defensive purposes, of course.
Liar!
I already know that Metal Gear is nothing but a nuclear
equipped.
Stop shaking him!
Nuclear?
Why are you acting like a bully?
He's like a high school bully to him.
The terrorists are planning to use Metal Gear to launch a
nuclear missile.
Oh, it's Zone of the Ender.
Oh my god.
Aren't they just trying to use the TMD missile module to
launch a disabled nuclear warhead?
He's so unbothered by it, which is even funnier.
The purpose of this exercise was to test Metal Gear's
nuclear launch capability using a dummy nuclear warhead.
The terrorists are just continuing the work you started.
No, you're wrong.
I heard it directly from your boss, Baker.
No.
A nuclear missile on Rex?
So you really didn't know.
A lot of con.
Little babies.
He's like, right here.
All the armament was built by a separate department.
The...
And the president personally supervised the final assembly
with the main unit.
The picture on his badge looks like...
President Baker.
Looks like his PS, like the original...
Metal Gear model.
I only know it's equipped with a Vulcan cannon, a laser, and
a rail gun.
Rail gun!
Do you guys remember that old video?
Nail gun!
It uses magnets to fire bullets at extremely high
velocities.
Every time they say rail gun, it makes me want to say it.
The technology was originally developed for the SDI system
and later scrapped.
We were successful in miniaturizing it in a joint venture
between Arms Tech and Rivermore National Labs.
The rail gun is on Rex's right arm.
Metal Gear's main function is to launch nuclear missiles.
You sure you're not forgetting something?
It's true that Metal Gear has a missile module on his back
that can be used.
carry up to eight missiles but are you saying it was
originally meant to carry nuclear missiles
oh yeah but that's not all I think if Metal Gear fired only
standard nuclear missiles then they should already have all
the practical data they need Ristelle welcome to my push-up
thank you so much could it be
metal gears co-developer labs was working on a new type of
nuclear weapon they were using Nova and NIF laser nuclear
fusion testing equipment and supercomputers well so they
developed a new type of nuclear weapon in a VR testing lab
huh yes but you can't use virtual data on a battlefield they
would need actual launch data hmm these are some of the
supercomputers if you link these you can test everything in
a Leo, how can the membership?
Thank you!
It's all just theoretical.
So, this exercise was designed to test the real thing.
What did our president do?
Oh, Otakai.
The terrorists launched that thing?
No.
Oh, and you're Nikes.
Damn!
Damn.
I'm such a fool.
Snakes.
It's all my fault.
No, it's a- The truth is...
My grandfather was part of the Manhattan Project.
He suffered with a guilt for the rest of his life.
And my father?
He was born on August 6th, 1945.
The day of the Hiroshima bomb.
Huey is the devil.
God's got a sense of humor, all right.
He is the devil.
Three generations of Emmerich men.
I can't with that.
must have the curse of nuclear weapons written into our DNA
no Huey I used to think that guy sucks he's the literal
devil I was the one being used no how you didn't know that's
only an anime oh no how that's enough crying pull yourself
together you're so mean in this where is metal gear where on
this base are they keeping it anime is real how yeah rex is
in the underground maintenance base where's that where north
of the communications tower but it's a long way there the
emergency override system for the detonation code is there
too yeah in the base's control room you'd better hurry if
they were planning a launch from the start then their
ballistic program is probably finished and since They
haven't called for me in a few hours.
They must not need me in other words.
They must be ready to launch We gotta go stop it code
override keys.
Yeah, we gotta put in the override keys and stop it for sure
We'll have to destroy Rex.
Yeah.
Oh no I need to I need to use that guy in the later game Oh
you're hurt you'll just slow me down.
Oh You'll need me if you're gonna destroy Rex true.
I don't need you Hey, you said earlier I need that guy.
I created Rex.
It's my right.
My duty to destroy him.
If you get a chance, try to escape.
Don't do that.
When the coast is clear, I'll contact you by Kodak.
How am I supposed to escape from an island?
Okay.
Last luck on the membership.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for joining me.
We appreciate it.
I want you to hide somewhere and keep me informed.
You know this place well, don't you?
do and don't worry I've got this oh well it's the same
stealth technology as he looks so much like Foxhound was
gonna use them but with the glass I'll be fine bad leg and
all and he looks so much like MGS one but I want Meryl to
watch out you too thank you for the birthday wait did Snake
just smile that's what that would be 32 thank you okay
that's a relief I want you to look after him that music now
very close there she is Oh no, damn, they spotted me.
Oh no!
Merrill, what happened?
Merrill, Merrill.
Mario!
Something's wrong.
Did you hear something?
Wasn't that some kind of music?
Some kind of music.
Mario!
What did she look like?
She's got a nice butt.
We know that for sure.
She's kind of cute the way she walks.
She...
She was wearing the same green uniform as the terrorists.
Oh.
And she- If she's disguised as the enemy, you'll have to
contact her when she's alone, huh?
Wait, you didn't talk about her butt!
There's only one place where we can be sure she's by
herself.
You didn't talk about her butt!
Where's that?
Don't be so dense.
Oh, the girl's bathroom.
Here, use this security card.
Otakon is a gentleman now.
It's security level four.
You guys, it was too raunchy for Nintendo, okay?
Nintendo said, oh, no, no, no.
No talking about girls' butts, please.
You're not in pain, are you?
Huh?
No.
You feel okay?
This part.
Nothing bothering you.
What's wrong?
You're all friendly all of a sudden.
No, nothing.
I'm just glad you're okay.
You're strange.
I'm a little nervous Everyone else I've saved suddenly dies
Your bad luck Your bad luck Forget it, doctor If I shoot
those guys, do they make sounds Like Keto time?
Call me Otakon It stands for Otakon Oh, sorry, spoilers,
sorry What does it stand for?
It stands for Otaku Convention An Otaku is a guy like me who
likes Japan animation Yeah!
Oh, oh yeah Yeah.
Yeah.
Is this one of the enders?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah.
This is the first country to successfully make bipedal
robots.
They're still the best in the field of robotics.
And Japanese cartoons played some part in that?
They did.
I didn't get into science to make nuclear weapons, you know.
I just wanted to make robots.
Yeah, that's what all scientists.
Why are we zooming in on them?
Stop.
The product placement is too obvious now.
Stop it.
Really?
It's true.
It sounds like an excuse to me.
We get it!
This is on the GameCube.
You're right.
We have to take responsibility.
Bad love equals beat out equals boys.
Science has progressed because there is war.
And because of scientists' greed, weapons of mass
destruction were born.
But you're not greedy, Otacon.
But that's all over.
You just want to make robots.
I won't take part in murder anymore.
Yeah.
You're a good boy.
Good guy, Otacon.
whatever all I want from you is information sure I know
everything about this whole why you got to touch him like
that though ask me anything about Rex or about this place
also with this stealth camouflage I can sneak in and out of
the armory in mess hall if you need ammo or rations just
tell me and I'll bring them to you uh-huh yeah I know you
will I'm on frequency 141.12 one four one
Otacon looks like my uncle?
You have a hot uncle then.
Yippee!
Did he change his pants?
I don't think he did.
Why do they give you bullets in this if...
Like can you actually shoot Grey Fox?
I've always just punched him.
him to death it's
clean he must drink a lot of water oh
my gosh that looks similar to the controller i'm using now
wowie it's a game cube wait can i shoot this thing oh sorry
pencil Yoshi.
Yoshi!
Goodbye, Mario.
Oh no!
Why did my life show up?
Yoshi!
So cute!
So
cute!
Does Mario heal you?
No way!
Is that why it says...
That one makes sense.
What's this?
Oh, it's the...
That's so funny.
Wait, what's on this computer?
Actually, I think he destroyed this computer.
Oh, no, he didn't.
Accessing?
Port?
Some of those of them.
Can't tell.
in here, so much science.
I want the box.
Let's go.
Let's save real quick.
Maybe.
Snake, there's an old Chinese saying.
A scholar who cherishes the love of comfort is not fit to be
deemed a scholar.
Einstein said it another way.
He said that only a life lived for others is worth living.
that's why i entered mit instead of cmu or princeton like my
friends boo princeton physics not just theoretical stuff
yeah i wanted to make things for people we wanted we wanted
to do real stuff or the codec system you're so awesome
maling i just wanted to make something that would be useful
for people yeah i think that it was the same for dr emirate
too no but he was used like a tool used to make a horrible
killing machine just like snake used by everybody it would
As a machine.
As a weapon.
I don't know.
No.
You're wrong.
There's at least one person whose life has gotten better as
a result of your inventions.
Without the Kodak, I wouldn't be able to talk to you like
this.
Thanks, Snake.
Aww.
Wee.
So sweet.
Oh.
Actually, I forgot.
I want to see if she still does this.
Do not save.
Good luck, Snake.
Thanks, Mealing.
What's up, Snake?
Good luck, Snake.
Thank you.
What can I do for you, Snake?
Come on, Snake.
I just want to look at your snake.
Don't call me for no reason.
I just want to look at your pretty face.
She gets upset.
She's so cute.
Oh, she's upset at me.
Oh, maybe one more time.
I love the squint.
She really said.
Babe.
Cute.
Well, it looks like you've rescued Emmerich for the time
being.
With that stealth camouflage, he should be able to hide
safely.
Grey Fox.
I can't believe it.
But the real problem is your niece.
She's a problem.
She was supposed to be a good girl.
Something must have happened to her.
Why wasn't she a good girl?
Shut up, Naomi.
Not exactly.
It's just that she's holding the detonator.
nation code override oh i just thought you were human for a
second there are last chance of stopping that nuclear launch
my mistake you're a cold man your mission is more important
than the life of your companions you're a cold man this is
war survival is the name of the game sometimes you have to
be called to survive yes but snake either way i want you to
find merrill as soon as possible i understand it is kind of
bad that he said that in front of campbell i feel like in
front of the little you know Merrill no response let's try
master more in war a split second can mean the difference
between victory and defeat don't ever hesitate the slower
you react the greater the chance that you'll be beaten why
does he sound out of breath did you hear that he was like in
war the every second counts don't think
Don't waste any second.
Why did...
Are you okay, Master Miller?
Are you on the treadmill or something?
That inner voice that warns you when danger is nearby?
You can't learn that in training.
You've got to have survived a few firefights.
Seen a few friends blown away before you learned that trick.
He sounds so like breathy.
I don't understand why.
Alright, guys.
Before we continue onwards, I'm going to go...
set my oven.
I'm going to turn on my oven and I'm going to set an alarm
for like five minutes or something or I'll do like 10
minutes and then um and then um go put my pizza in the oven
so I can have some food.
Bro is getting back shots.
Well back shots while on the wait what's a back shot?
And what time is it?
Let's set it for 9...
No, that's not...
Let's set it for 9.05.
Thank you!
Yeah.
Oh, not AM?
No, no, no.
PM, PM.
Okay, set for...
9 minutes from now.
Oh, wait.
Let me set it a little...
It should heat up in like 10 minutes, alright?
Okay, I'll be right back.
gonna go heat up or i'm gonna go set the oven for my pizza
brb mint don't look it up wait what what am i looking up
hold on hold on i'm on a timer give me a second
oh i just hit my knee ah
okay i'm back okay so in nine minutes it should be heated up
maybe and then we can i'll go put my pizza in.
And then I'll set another timer.
Pizza.
Bashamine!
Oh, hiya!
Backshots are when you throw your ball backwards towards the
hoop.
No need to look it up now.
You're welcome.
Oh, so it's like a basketball thing.
Makes... Well, he's...
Oh, my God.
Master Miller's shooting the hoops.
On the job?
Master Miller...
Pay attention to me.
Okay, the way you guys are describing it is making me
scared.
I'm just gonna believe whatever.
Whatever.
Let's listen to Sasha instead.
Otacon said that now it's possible to design and test new
types of nuclear weapons in a virtual simulation without
ever exploding a nuclear device.
What kind of pizza is this?
It's just cheese pizza.
Yes, it's true.
Since the establishment of Dart, a dual-axis radiographic
hydrodynamic test facility and NIF, the national ignition
facility early in the 21st century there's been a wealth of
data concerning nuclear fission and fusion fission and
fusion there is also much data accumulated from the nuclear
tests conducted over the last four decades with the
processing speed of today's supercomputers they can design a
new nuclear weapon through virtual reality computer
simulations mint are you going to do a full run in one
setting no no I think maybe after psychomantis maybe since
he's coming up relatively soon right yeah we go to
psychomanus then we go through to we'll see oh i went the
wrong way um maybe after psychomanus
and then i'll probably do the rest of it next week i'll
i don't know we'll see Mm-hmm.
Oh, nice.
Everything's still broken.
Uh, Otacon gave me his his stuff, right?
His card?
What card key do I have now?
Four.
Metal Gear Exercise Data.
Number four.
Was there four over here?
Bip-bip!
Did I go in here before?
Oh.
Nakita bullet full.
I think I went in this one before already.
And I just...
Oh!
Night vision goggles!
What?
How did I miss that?
Wait, how did I actually miss that before?
It's kind of crazy.
Oh, uh oh.
Oh, how do I get out of here?
Run, snake, run!
Go, go, go!
Oh, level four door.
Okay, that makes way more sense.
I was gonna say, I thought there was a door that we could...
Okay.
Oh.
B1, baby.
Where are cameras?
I shot them down.
Okay, I'm gonna try and hold up the guy going
to the bathroom.
Now pee without using your hands.
I don't need any more rations right now.
But you're like...
Ew, why is that in the stall?
That's nasty.
Okay, come in.
Get in there.
Yep.
Good night.
Uh-oh.
Uh-uh.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh, I didn't realize that.
Um.
Freeze.
You're also going in the stall.
Pizza time?
What do you mean, pizza time?
My alarm hasn't gone off yet.
You guys are set an alarm.
Get in there.
This is where Psycho Mantis is.
Oh, I was like, what are those two dots?
But it's a It's our friendly, it's our little guys.
We can't go into the girl's room, unfortunately.
Oh, wait.
Is that her?
Easy.
Wow, the bathroom got, like, such an upgrade.
Oh, my gosh.
It's so nice.
There's a little place to do your makeup.
It's so fancy in here now.
I don't
have the toilet paper on the floor.
That's disgusting.
Freeze.
You.
You trickster.
I let my guard down because you're beautiful.
That's the second time I've been able to sneak up on the
legendary solid snake.
What a peeper.
Ow!
Oh!
you're Meryl you're hot oh no wait my alarm oh no no hold on
oh gosh what do you mean hey men aren't allowed in here hold
on I gotta get to the cutscene I had no idea you were so
feminine this is no time to try and hit on me snake she has
psychosis besides it's a waste of time exactly when I joined
up Psychotherapy.
Psychotherapy.
Yeah.
Same smart mouth.
You're Merrill, all right.
Are you hurt?
Pizza time.
Not yet.
After all, I was disguised as a genome soldier.
So why'd you change?
You'd be a lot better off dressed like one of them.
I got tired of disguising myself.
Rip pizza?
No, it's just, uh, it's just the oven.
I gotta go put the pizza inside.
The uniform smelled like blood.
Ew.
What's that mark?
What is this music?
Oh, this?
It's a paint tattoo.
It's not real.
I'm a fan of Foxhound way back when guys like you and my
uncle were in it.
This is a weird soundtrack.
None of that gene therapy like there is today.
You guys were real heroes.
There are no heroes in war.
It's funny you mention that.
All heroes I know are either dead or in prison.
One or the other.
But Snake, her foundation does not match the rest of her
body.
She looks like...
I'm just a guy who can only find meaning on the battlefield.
There's no winning or losing for a mercenary.
The only winners in war are the people.
That's right.
And you fight for the people.
She thinks she's way paler than she actually is.
I've never fought for anyone but myself.
I've got no purpose in life.
No ultimate goal.
I don't like the music yet.
Come on.
It's only when I'm cheating death on the battlefield.
I feel truly alive Truly alive seeing other people die makes
you feel alive, huh?
I mean you can't stop loving war Is it the same for all
soldiers throughout history?
No interest in men yet marries the toilet man?
Hey, he was very convincing.
Why didn't you contact me?
Yeah, actually.
Oh my god.
Oh, your shoes.
Oh my god, not in the bathroom Shouldn't you just be happy
we met up like this girly please.
Oh my god.
You're no so nasty oh anyway how did you recognize me in
disguise you got a nice never forget a lady so there's
something you like about me huh yeah you've got a great butt
what oh i see first it's my eyes now it's my butt what's
next on the battlefield you never think about what's next
angle
Love it.
Love that.
Love that for you, Snake.
I miss this guy.
So, Snake, how are the negotiations going?
No progress.
Negotiations?
So it's all up to you, huh?
Somebody's got to stop them from launching a nuclear
missile.
There are two ways.
Either we destroy Metal Gear or...
We override the detonation code.
You got the card keys from Baker?
Hi You mean this way was that where are the others there
should be three keys?
This is all I've got Where could the other two be?
I have no idea but they must be somewhere if we can't find
them We'll have no choice but to destroy metal here ladies
on this whole I heard that metal gears and another ladies
washroom floor is pretty clear take me to I know this place
better than you do you'll just slow me down down you don't
have enough battle experience i won't slow you down i
promise she says that and then she gets shot and slows us
down then you can shoot me wow i don't like to waste bullets
none of that gene therapy nonsense you guys are real heroes
woman who goes in all in on nanos a few years later okay to
be fair it's like 10 years later so spoilers sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry Sorry.
Sorry.
No spoilers.
Got it.
I'll be careful.
You know, I don't use makeup the way other women do.
No, you don't because it looks very bad.
I hardly ever look at myself in the mirror.
Maybe you should look more.
Because, oh no, she's not like other girls.
I've always dreamed of becoming a soldier.
Your foundation.
It wasn't really my dream.
My father he was killed in action when I was younger You
wanted to follow in your father's footsteps Not really I
thought that if I became a soldier, I could understand him
better And it looks good here you became a soldier looks
like she tries to blend it in with her neck at least I
Thought I was until today Now I understand Truth is I was
just afraid of looking at myself Afraid of having to make my
own decisions in life.
I'm so sad about the music change.
But I'm not gonna lie to myself anymore.
I'll do it myself.
It's time I took a long, hard look at myself.
I want to know who I am, what I'm capable of.
I want to know why I've lived the way I've lived until now.
I want to know...
Take a good look.
You won't be seeing mirrors for a while.
There won't be any chances to wash your face either.
No, your foundation.
This isn't a training exercise.
Our lives are riding on this.
Yeah.
There are no heroes or heroines.
No.
You lose.
You die a dog's death.
A dog's death.
Yeah.
Is that Fama's functional?
Oh.
I have one, too.
Unfortunately, it's out of ammo.
Oh.
Where'd you get that desert eagle?
I found it in the armory.
Ah!
It's a...
50 caliber action express there was a so calm pistol too but
I chose this like give us the leftovers so I got a leftover
huh isn't that gun a little big for a girl hey snake now you
treat me like a woman come on use my 45 I want the she's
like give me that bigger guy I've used a gun like this since
I was eight years old I'm more comfortable with it than I am
with a bra whoa Yes, Snake.
If we're gonna go north, we'll have to go through the
commander's room on this floor.
The overland route is blocked by glaciers.
The door to the commander's room is security level 5.
But you got the key.
This card will open it.
Ah, yeah.
Why does this like lighting on Snake's face?
Looks like he's got like a lightning bolt.
It was inside the pocket of the uniform I was wearing.
Nice.
It looks like he must have been guarding someplace
important.
Could have used that earlier.
Okay, let's go.
I know this place better than you.
I'll be point, man.
Follow me.
Oh.
She's going.
She's running.
Why is he in Australia?
What happened to the music?
I'll keep a lookout.
Make sure you're ready, okay?
What happened to the music?
Okay, give me one second.
the codec real quick um i'm gonna go put my pizza in the
oven so then uh we'll run around and then um we'll wait a
little bit until my pizza's cooked because it shouldn't take
too long it should take like 10 minutes and i don't want to
be in the middle of mantis's fight when when uh it goes off
so give me sorry i know i keep leaving um but give me like
you know two minutes to put it into the oven and yeah i'll
be right back
All right, let me set a timer for, oh, yeah.
Let me set a timer for 10 minutes.
Thank you for all the super ties, thank you, thank you.
10 minutes would be 25.
Okay, save.
Okay.
All right, let's grab some stuff.
Actually, let's, we can call the codec first.
is fine thank goodness thank goodness we can't relax not yet
no i know snake uh she's quite a woman as commander of this
operation i can't ask you to watch after merrill but duty
first maybe i was wrong sending my own flesh and blood to
war she understands about duty i know she does welcome back
but what i want to know is what was the real purpose of this
military exercise i don't know I'm nothing more than a
middleman.
Is this transmission being monitored by the military?
Of course.
I get it.
All the world's a stage and we're merely players, right?
Yes.
But even players can influence the play.
I just hope we can prevent it from having a bad ending.
Thanks for the beat.
What did I call Meryl?
She right there?
Oh, no response.
Come on, girlie.
Come on.
it you managed to link up with merrill yeah good so now you
must have the card keys that will override the detonation
yes we're gonna override that hurry the time limit is
running out oh my gosh we only probably have like two hours
see nastasha you found merrill the colonel will be so
relieved oh okay it's a good thing you hooked up with
merrill you should have seen the colonel He doesn't like to
let it show because he's the boss, but he was so happy he
could barely contain himself.
Oh, that's right.
Her codec is broken.
That's right.
You're right.
Why did I keep saying hook up with her?
I don't really like the...
Oops.
I don't really like that wording.
Oh.
Talk to you later, Snake.
Bye.
Wait.
I'm looking at you.
What?
What is it?
Oh, I almost punched her.
Why are you staring at my...
Oh, I'm not staring at your face.
Why are you staring at my face?
Why are you...
Come on, Snake.
Don't stare at me like that.
She doesn't look to be getting redder.
Does she?
Why are you staring at my face?
We've got to get a move on.
She's so shy.
Your face.
What?
What is it?
She doesn't seem to be getting redder, does she?
Takes a while?
Why are you staring at my...
Face.
It's the foundation.
It's covering her blush.
So true.
Come on, Snake.
It doesn't take that long in the original.
Hmm.
like that what's wrong with your fries why aren't you
staring at my fries what are you doing we've got to get a
move on she's so like if she could like woo-woo finger like
index finger index finger what she would is it she's so like
she's oh my god right now she's giving Bella from twilight
why are you staring at Mike she's giving she's so Bella from
twilight she's like Come on, Snake.
Okay, I don't think she's gonna turn red.
That's a little sad, but...
Are these guys still in here?
Even they are gone?
Okay.
Everyone's gone, so I'm taking advantage of the situation,
baby.
Yeah, let's take that.
Bombs bullets are full.
Uh, what's this?
Oh!
Wait!
That's the Pazaza meme!
Oh, sorry.
Don't hit me.
Get out of my way, Meryl.
Wait, why is the name of the position being different?
What's this?
Oh, call soup.
Sorry.
Oh, I'm hiding now.
Oh.
What does this say?
Notice.
Oh, no, no, not yet.
Over here, yep.
Stung grenade.
Oh, no more in the key that...
Why is there so many?
They're all just chilling out.
Everything is...
I think I'm good, honestly, on everything.
I don't think I could get anything else.
Unless there's, like, a...
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, I'm good on everything.
It's a well-stocked office.
Yes, it is.
Nice.
I don't think there's anything under these ones.
I don't think I can remember.
Sorry.
Stay out.
This is what I mean, Meryl.
Like, you're in my way, Meryl.
Okay.
Um, hold on.
Let me have, how much time?
Okay, I have five minutes before my pizza's done.
Like I said, I don't want to get into Psycho Mantis and,
like, have to stop mid-fight.
Hmm.
Let's just listen to this ASMR of their footsteps.
Oh my god.
The sound, this is so like...
Wait, what's going on?
Snake, let's hurry up and go to the commander's room.
I'm sorry!
Oh.
She is not having it.
She is leaving without me.
What kind of pizza?
It's just cheese pizza.
It's just a cheese pizza.
Can I go back into the girl's bathroom?
I'm not going to see mirror.
Mirrors for very long anymore, so...
Whoa!
Um, wait.
I'm a handsome fella, aren't I?
Working mirrors, yeah.
Technology.
Wash your hands.
Maybe there's stuff in here, too.
We haven't checked.
Nice.
Is this the one with the toilet on the ground?
Oh.
Excuse me, Meryl.
I have to go to the little girl's room.
And let's also...
Sniffa.
Sniffa, sniff, sniff, sniff.
Okay.
We're just wasting time right now.
but no
way it works okay hold on hold on we gotta wash our hands
get under the fingernails
all dry did you hear about the marines in real life who
fooled an ai security camera during training by sneaking
around in a cardboard box i have heard about that i have i
have okay god this sound is just so it's like the barbie
movie oh it's so satisfying look at her like slapping her
thigh with her gun she looks so cool
freeze i probably shouldn't joke with that because i will
make a mistake I will accidentally shoot her.
Or purposefully.
Okay, just one more minute, you guys.
Actually, I'm just gonna go.
I'm just gonna go get my pizza out of the oven.
Okay, I'll BRB one more time.
I'm so sorry.
BRB, BRB, BRB.
Pizza is served.
They're really hot, though, so I gotta let them cool before
I.
really need to eat before i fight him um so maybe it would
take like a little bit of a break a little bit of a break
well they need to cool down oh actually you know what i'll
eat once they're cool and in the middle of the battle maybe
i just realized something oh also i'm gone i'm missing ah oh
no no oh i put my thing on backwards hold on i have to fix
my headband Um, good enough.
Uh, I realized something.
Um, for Psychomantis, um, you know how, like, you have to
change the controller port and all that fun stuff.
What?
What do I do on the GameCube?
Um, uh, well, Colonel will tell me.
Colonel will tell me, right?
Oh, sorry.
Colonel will tell me.
yes oh my gosh what's wrong snake don't you like girls out
out out it's okay it's hot it's hot she's so cute oh no
thinking my head it hurts to think it hurts I'm just a woman
Oh, don't come here, Snake.
Whoa, whoa, I'm getting motion sick for real.
Too many thighs.
I don't think she's okay, Snake.
I don't think she's okay.
What happened?
I'm fine.
Hi, Hannah.
Oh.
Oh, what is...
Okay, let's go.
Oh, come on, Mr. Foxhound.
The commander is waiting.
Wait, where's our extra like...
That's the extra like zoomies and stuff.
That's what you take away.
But you'll add in everything else to this version.
I like that line, though.
The commander is waving.
Also, oh, oh, there it is.
I was going to say, when you look at her, it's you looking
at her, but oh, it switches.
Oh, my gosh, that's kind of cool.
Whoa.
But you can't move it.
You can't move around or anything.
Oh.
That is pretty cool.
Beep, beep.
And also, she's red on on the thing now.
The commander is waiting.
Oh!
Can you trank her?
I wonder in this part, actually.
If we can trank her instead.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Whoa, whoa!
Caution, stand back!
Girlie?
Can't you read?
Do you like me?
What the?
She's getting handsy with us.
Whoa!
No, don't go any lower.
Do you like me?
That's for Hal.
Whoa.
Hold me.
Snake.
Whoa, whoa.
What's wrong?
You're psychotherapy.
Hurry.
Please.
Make left me.
The fact that Psycho Mantis is saying all this, that's one
freaky guy.
Oh,
okay, hold on.
Do I need to do something now?
I'm eating pizza.
Oh!
That wasn't me.
Merrill's not herself.
Don't use your weapon.
I was only starting the codec!
He's controlling Merrill.
That tune is his mind control music.
Don't use your weapon.
Try to knock her out.
Okay.
Oh, he shot me?
That's so messed up.
I was answering the codec.
Oh!
Whoa!
Wait, I forgot how to shoot all of a sudden.
There we go.
She's out?
Useless woman.
Optic camouflage, huh?
Who are these guys?
I hope that's not your only trick.
You doubt my power.
Now, I will show you why I am the most powerful
practitioner.
of psychokinesis and telepathy in the world.
No, there's no need for words, Snake.
I am psychomancers.
Nyam!
That's right.
Doug Stone is so awesome.
It's true power.
Who's the white guy?
I told you.
I can read your every thought.
Kojima!
In the middle.
it's like called mintus oh you're a careless man aren't you
hey what are you trying to say huh however you are a skilled
warrior you like brute force sure you are extremely cautious
around traps yeah i am yeah i am still don't believe me now
i'll read more deeply into your soul on the ground in front
of us.
I see that you enjoy Nintendo games.
You like Silicon Knights games, don't you?
So, you like adventure games?
Did you enjoy playing eternal darkness?
I'll be honest.
You seem to like the legend of Zelda, don't you?
I had a friend help me set up the memory card.
You like action games?
you've been playing Super Mario Sunshine haven't you just
for this part oh so you've played Super Smash Brothers melee
before no I have not you have saved often you are a prudent
person I'm a prudent person I can read you like an open book
you still don't believe me I will show you my psychokinetic
power put your controller on the floor okay I'm actually
going to put it close to the mic put it down as flat as you
can I'm not touching it though I mean I'm holding it up oh
he's looking at me okay I'm sorry that's good okay it's flat
on my hands controller by the power of my will alone not the
fourth wall break okay here we go oh oh it's barely moving
oh my god it's barely shaking I don't even think you can
hear it thanks to your friend for saying what
you think now can you feel my power
The demonstration is over.
Stop drop and roll!
What is going on?
What?
Roll, what, what?
Huh?
I don't remember.
The pictures.
Wait, they're back to normal.
Um...
That was weird.
Colonel,
what do I do?
No, not you, Naomi!
KGB psychic.
He has powerful psychokinetic and telepathic abilities.
After the collapse of the Soviet Union, he came to America
looking for a job.
I'm sorry, it's so funny.
because he was jobless.
He was unemployed.
As a result, he became just like the killer.
So he was sort of infected by this serial murderer's
thoughts?
In any case, after that, he became sort of a psychic spy
working...
Wait, this music is not...
He traveled all around the world.
That's when he was recruited by a foxhound.
This is not it.
He knows every move that you're going to make.
What should I do?
I got no chance of beating him.
must be some way he's a master of controlling people's night
don't let him manipulate you I don't know about the music I
think we just got blasted yep m9 I don't need that oh I
guess for Meral oh nice um oh my god okay maybe I have to
try shooting him oh shit out okay I have to remember his
patterns again oh god oh god oh that's ah oh no he's right
there oh god no no not these guys please oh See, I'll
just...
Colonel, help me!
How do I shoot him?
I don't know what to do!
Not everything you see with your two eyes is real.
Destroying his spirit is more important than destroying his
body.
Don't let him read you.
Okay.
Be a blank slate.
Clear your mind.
Um...
His...
Destroy his spirit.
Uh, hey, Bozo.
Oh, God.
You look really dumb with that, uh...
Oh, my God.
You look really stupid with that mask on!
Uh...
Uh, you...
Your pants are ugly!
Oh, my God.
Oh, why don't you grow some hair, Baldi?
I don't
know what port to put in.
Put in.
What port do I put it in?
Where do I put it in, Campbell?
He's using his psychic ability to read your controller's
moves.
That's how he's evading your attack.
Okay, I'm gonna try port 2.
You don't do something so he can't read your controller's
moves.
Think.
There must be some way.
Okay, I'm on port 2 right now.
There's four slots!
What?
How did that hit me?
I was on the ground.
Oh.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh my god, no, no, no, no.
Where are you?
Oh, where is he?
I
can't tell actually if I'm just bad or...
No, dang it.
Okay, actually this remix is kind of awesome.
Ouch.
Okay, hold on.
It's not port two.
Turtle.
He's using his psychic ability to read your controller's
moves.
That's how he's evading your attack.
Okay, I'm gonna try.
Port three!
Okay.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I blend in with the floor!
Where are you?
There you are.
Come on, stop it.
Stop moving.
Did I get you?
Oh!
Nice!
Okay, point three!
Oh, well, oh, that's my arrow.
That didn't work.
Cut it out!
I can't.
Is it working?
Oh, it doesn't seem to be working.
Oh my god, not this thing again.
Not this guy, please.
Let's get here.
Oh, there's saw combos.
Uh, where are you at?
There you are.
Oh my gosh.
He's so slippery.
This guy is moving everywhere.
are hitting him like I know a bad but like even
when he's still
oh no he dodged it still wait colonel colonel wait wait
colonel I think I got wait huh Is there any reason you can't
use controller socket 4?
What?
Oh, okay.
4 is a spooky number.
That's why.
Okay, we got this now.
Maybe.
Oh, if I can aim.
If I can aim for it.
That was so funny.
Oh, child!
These things suck.
Gosh, dang it, this guy again.
He's right there!
Actually, what if I use the FAMIS instead?
Where are you?
Come here.
Where did you go?
And, uh, shoot!
Whoa, whoa, where'd you go?
Oh, dang.
This is so scuffed.
Oh, oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I was gonna say it's way easier than the, uh...
than the original one.
It's just funny.
It's just funny how...
Hello, it's, uh...
Okay.
And...
Back to...
Oh, not this guy again.
This is kind of the best spot.
Oh, this is so funny.
Oh.
Oh, not Meryl again.
Okay, this is fine though.
This is fine.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What's going on?
Uh...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Oh, girly.
Ah!
Gurly!
Hold on!
We'll get her, we'll get her down.
Come on.
There we go.
Easy peasy.
Stop it, Meryl.
Meryl.
Ow!
Oh, that was close.
Meryl.
Stop.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my god.
Oh, I thought me punching her did enough.
Okay, that should be good now.
Okay.
Okay, it's so fast.
Oh, oh, I ran right into that.
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
What?
I cannot read you.
Oh, where did you go?
Nobody?
Oh, no.
Where are you?
Ow!
Oh.
He's so fast.
I shot him in the butt.
Oh, uh, oh, dang it.
I pressed X too slowly.
Oh, they're all coming out.
Oh, he's pulling out all the stops.
That's fine.
I can still hit you.
Colonel, your niece is going to be Okay.
Is she?
No way.
The boss fights in this are crazy.
But why did you go so far out of your way to save her?
For Campbell's sake?
Or maybe it's because you like her.
I don't want to see any woman die right in front of me.
Or a person.
You know?
I don't want to see anyone die.
Since when did anybody's death bother you so much?
Naomi.
It's true that Snake has killed a lot of people.
doesn't have a heart.
It's okay, Colonel.
She's right.
Nah, just women.
Thank you, thank you.
It's still possible to beat Psychomancers by dying twice and
calling the Colonel afterwards to find out what's during the
statue bus.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Should I switch back to port one?
Does it matter at this point?
Control or port?
Yeah, sorry.
I wasn't able to read the future.
I know.
I'm like trying port two, port three.
And then Colonel's just like, hey, any reason you haven't
switched to port four, dummy?
I will read your future.
To get to Metal Gear's underground maintenance base, you
have to go through the hidden door.
There's a hidden door behind the bookcase.
Yeah.
Called out.
I thought, well, I hit him that one time.
Go past the communication towers.
So I thought with the three port, it was fine.
Long time.
Elfrey, thank you!
First time clear.
I know.
This game is way easier.
You don't need to thank, or you don't need to congratulate
me.
Thank you so much for that.
Thank you so much.
Oh, disgusting.
Oh, God.
Oh, you're so mean, Meryl.
And each mind that I peered into was stuffed with the same
single object of obsession.
That selfish and that avistic desire to pass on one seed.
It wasn't enough to make me sick.
Every living thing on this planet exists to mindlessly pass
on their DNA.
We're designed that way and that is why there is war.
Is that?
But you... Is that it?
I don't know about that.
You're the same as us.
We have no past, no future.
Aw, no snake has his dogs.
That's our only purpose.
He has his dogs.
Humans weren't designed to bring each other happiness.
Kind of like that they're not showing his face.
From the moment we're thrown into this world, we're fated to
bring each other nothing but pain and pain.
Oh, just kidding.
The first person whose mind I dove into was my father's.
Don't scare.
I saw nothing but disgust and hatred for me.
It is hard.
Because I was thinking in, like, uh...
My mother died in childbirth.
In the original, they show his face, obviously, but...
But it's more low-poly, so you can't really tell how he
looks exactly.
That's when my future disappeared.
Voldemort converted.
He hasn't met past as well.
When I came to, the village was engulfed in flames.
Huh.
your village down to bury your past I see that you have
suffered the same trauma we are truly the same you and I the
world is a more interesting place with people like you in it
I never agreed with the boss's revolution his dreams of
World conquest do not interest me.
I just want an excuse to kill as many people as I courted.
You monster.
Let him talk.
Yeah.
He doesn't have much time left.
I've seen true evil.
Snake, seeing you calms my soul.
Let him cook.
I'm the boss.
No, worse.
that's so messed up compared to you i'm like a saint how
could you even say that i read her mind as well merrill's i
saw you there you have a large place in her heart a large
place and getting bigger oh what i do not know if your
futures lie together oh they do not getting bigger i have a
last request what is it my mask put it back on okay the
voices are too strong like this other people's thoughts
force their way into my mind before i die i want want to be
left alone in my own world no i really like psychomantis
i'll open the door for you if you want to find your future
go through that door the controller is rumbling more than
when he was controlling it this is the first time
someone Strange such a nostalgic feeling No
Even in a goofy version of the series like this gets me all
choked up Yeah, let's go Meryl I'm sorry Meryl How could I
let Mantis control my mind like that?
If you're going to doubt yourself, I'll leave you here.
You're right.
Don't regret your past.
Learn from it.
Regrets just make a person weaker.
So true, Snake.
You're right.
I'm sorry.
I won't do it again.
Snake, can I ask you something?
What's your name?
What's your birthday?
More complaints.
Your family.
About what Mantis said.
I was just wondering.
No regrets.
What?
What's the problem now?
Oh, no.
Nothing.
What's your issue?
What are you complaining about?
Are you cold?
What's your name?
Your real name.
I don't got one.
A name means nothing on the battlefield.
After a week, no one has a name.
How old are you?
Old enough.
Old enough to know what death looks like.
Any family?
No.
But I was raised by many people.
Is there anyone you like?
My dogs.
I've never been interested in anyone else's life.
My 50 huskies.
So you are all alone.
Just like Manta said.
Other people just complicate my life.
I don't like to get involved.
You're a sad, lonely man.
I like...
Come on, let's go.
I like the original more because I think in the original it
was more like kind of quick, like quick quips.
Like, how old are you?
Blah, blah, blah.
Where are you?
Like, how many people are in your family?
Blah, blah, blah.
Like, it was... Oh, oh!
Use controller!
There we go.
Look up.
Plugged it all back up.
Why is it so loud in my rumbly ears?
Who is this guy?
Who's that guy?
Actually, who's this guy too?
Oh, Silicon Knights guy!
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Wait, that's Yoji Sinkawa?
Is it actually?
He looks... No.
Is it?
He looks so young if that's him.
Is it actually Yoji Sinkawa?
Oh my gosh, I didn't recognize him because he looks so
young.
No way!
Oh my gosh.
I mean, so does Hideyo Kojima.
He looks so young.
Oh, sorry.
I'm gonna miss this sound.
So crisp.
Good night.
Good night, sweet prince.
Alright, let's go, Meryl.
Oh, let's save.
The tongues of dying men Tongs!
No, I didn't use tongues.
lie with their dying breaths I think he was telling the
truth maybe you should believe him hmm maybe you should
believe him now you can eat your pizza in peace actually
I've I already finished it I already finished my pizza
please snake don't give up don't give up I think actually
maybe we'll get to right like we'll get to
uh sniper wolf not finished sniper wolf we'll get to maryl
being down and then we can end it because uh i want to go
keep going just a little bit more it looks like maryl's okay
thanks snake you're welcome oh snake you want there's no
time left you've got to hurry up and get to the underground
base you should be able to go north from the commander's
room master miller What a pathetic man.
He was born with all the right tools, but he never knew how
to use them.
Never knew how to use them.
She's right behind me.
What if she's just like Snake?
I'm right here.
The enormous costs for the development of military weapons.
Are you eating your pizza while touching your controller
with greasy hands?
Sacralage.
No!
It's not, it wasn't that greasy of a pizza.
What'd you say?
I missed what Nostasha said because of you.
At the end of the Cold War, the old conflict patterns
collapsed and tension and controls were relieved.
Oh yeah, forgot about Otakon.
Sorry, Otakon.
Wait, is he listed?
I don't remember what his codec is.
Now, even economically weak countries can acquire military
strength.
Is he in here?
Oh no, what is Otakon's codec?
one for oh yes one for you only one two
a psychic soldier what a waste i guess fighting was all he
ever knew what are you feeling sorry for him sorry had
incredible power mr hater fantastic are you are you canadian
maybe that power could have been used to make people happy
did you say sorry it's a sad thing when you see all that
power being used just for war
What are you feeling sorry for?
Snake, Metal Gear is in an underground base to the north.
Hurry!
Snake!
Okay.
Alright.
EQ my show.
What's over here?
Nice.
Wait.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, girl.
Wow.
You don't have to be so dramatic about it, Meryl.
Sheesh.
Left picture is Ryuhei Kitamura, Japanese movie director who
directed the Twin Snake cutscenes.
I was gonna say...
Could there be wolves in here?
I was like...
Wolf dogs.
No wonder...
Okay, it's...
So it was like Yajishikawa.
I feel...
I don't feel as bad now.
How do you know so much?
Oh!
Five, six, seven, oh, no.
I'm a musher.
Oh my God.
I love it.
I'll take point.
Snake, you follow me.
Oh!
Ow!
Oh, that's where we crawl through.
Huh?
Whose footsteps are these?
Where'd you go?
Follow me.
To, um, where, madam?
You just left me...
You left me to die!
No.
We can fit through there.
Okay.
I believed it maybe in the original, but there...
No, we can fit through that.
Please do awu, a $40 reward.
Awu!
Ow, awu!
We can fit through that.
Snake, just go through.
Sounds kind of meaty.
We can fit through that.
Is this the way we came from?
How do I get the dogs to pee on my box?
Oh, I hear them.
I hear them growling.
Scary.
Oh, wait.
Actually, I can put them to sleep.
Oh.
Why is the music so scary?
Wait, why is the music so scary?
I'm scared.
Why is it so scary?
Pia si- Good to know that there's some ammo there, though.
Oh, oh, oh, wait, where is he coming from?
Dog!
Wait, where did- where am I coming from?
I'm like...
Oh, I saw it!
Okay.
This, wait, that's where we crawled out from, right?
Lay pee on my box.
Pee on my box.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, nice, nice, nice.
Wait, sniffing the ground for.
I need him to pee on my box so that we can get past the dogs
easily.
Oh yeah, I have to punch her.
That's right.
We punch her and then hide.
And then...
Wait, which way is it?
Wait.
It's so... I can't tell.
You know what, let's just go.
They're here?
Is this the correct spot?
What?
Uh...
Baby.
What's this?
Oh, this has a Mim.
Uh...
Nice.
Wait, is this a hole?
It's so hard to tell!
Oh my gosh, even in the original I can never remember.
Oh no.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, wait, this one, this one, this one.
Right?
Oh, yeah.
There she is.
And the dog.
The baby dog.
Oh, he likes...
Snake, what's wrong?
I thought you were good with dogs.
Why do they all like her?
It's because she's so cute.
Okay, so we gotta hit her.
Hide.
Hide!
I think I'm in trouble.
There's a whole cutscene.
Well, that didn't go as planned.
Too slow?
Okay, one more try, one more try.
I had it, I had it.
What are you thinking?
I had it, I had it, I had it.
You gotta get distant?
What are you doing?
Hold on, Meryl!
Ah!
Now they won't attack me.
Yay!
What are you doing?
Okay.
Come on, Meryl.
Let's get you...
Oh, sorry.
Let's get you in trouble.
We're so cute.
Okay.
I wish I could pet the dog.
Look how cute it is.
Oh my god, he's so cute.
Look at him.
He looks so happy.
Oh my gosh, so cute.
All right, let's go.
Okay, this place is mined.
I'll take point again.
Stay back, okay?
Okay.
But the radar isn't working.
And since we can't use the mind detector either.
No.
Leave it to me.
So what do you think?
Pretty good, huh?
How did you know where the mines were?
It sounds weird, but when Mantis dove into my mind, I was
able to see where the mines were placed.
Are you impressed?
Well, that odd caught me in the bite.
Ew!
Are you in front of me?
If...
Oh!
You know what?
It was worth that.
It
was worth that, I think.
Quite honestly.
Anyway...
Here I come!
Why are we, once again, standing in the middle of the way?
Why do we never learn our lesson?
Oh my god.
Why are you turning around?
No.
Oh my gosh.
Merrill.
Merrill, don't you know what that is?
Why are you guys just standing there?
Oh, she's actually...
She purposefully aimed for the leg
Oh my god
Like I know she wasn't trying to kill her Oh my god sniper
She's just getting every limb Dang Oh my gosh
Snipe for wool.
Snake, leave me and run.
Merle.
I guess I'm a rookie after all.
Oh, well, both of you are for standing in the middle of the
way.
Even I know that.
Her leg.
It's the oldest trick in the book.
You guys, this is actually the last time we will see Merle.
Sniper's using me for bait to lure you out.
This is the last time we will see Meryl.
Shoot me, Snake.
No.
My gun.
I can't reach it but myself.
Since we're going for the autocon exit, exit ending.
I promised I wouldn't slow you down.
I, I can still help.
It's actually her.
I want to help you.
This is actually her death.
It's so sad.
It's actually so sad.
Bye, Meryl.
I was a fool.
I wanted to be a soldier.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Meryl.
Oh!
War is meaningless.
Nothing comes out of war.
Oh, the...
Ew.
It's so like sad watching her trying to reach for her gun.
Don't give up on people.
So sad.
Don't forget me.
She'd been so dramatic despite dying.
Gosh, why are you going to be so dramatic, Meryl?
No, get out of here.
I love that scene in the original.
Meryl?
Colonel?
Damn.
Snake, it's a trap.
Who just said Colonel?
The sniper's trick to lure you out.
The sniper's waiting for you to go to help Meryl so he can
kick you off.
it it must be sniper wolf foxhound's best shooter snipers
usually work in pairs who said Colonel I know her Naomi
maybe for hours days or weeks it was like a woman's voice
she's just watching and waiting for you to expose yourself
not snake maybe so but Mara can't hold out that long snake
can you see wolf from where you are there's nowhere to hide
between here and the tower she must be on the second floor
of the tower if wolf is in the you perfectly it's a classic
sniper's position classic at that distance you won't be able
to hit her with a standard weapon either you'll need a
sniper rifle the pst take it easy i'm going to save maryl no
matter what it takes okay thanks um what's wrong naomi pop
pop don't you know there's a tendency toward murder written
in your very genes so saving someone else's skin is out of
the question why are you gonna bring that up that I don't
know what the hell my genes look like and I don't care you
hate me so much Naomi like an animal I'm going to save
Merrill I don't need an excuse okay and I'm not doing it for
someone else either I'm going to save Merrill for myself
about that don't worry about that thanks I understand don't
don't thank me yet don't thank me yet Colonel you have no
reason to thank me
I love that scene in the original where like the codec is
just like going off over and over again and snake is just
sitting there like Oh my god, what do I do?
What do I do?
Like he's just he's not moving.
He's just like thinking.
Ah!
Wait, don't you like?
Oh, who who caught me then?
Oh my gosh, you are freaking me out little pup!
Please!
Those dogs after getting a whiff of newly-scented box on
snake.
Time to leave.
We're good now.
Everything's fine now.
What's this?
Oh, Fama's.
Sorry, guys.
Can always use more of that.
This is the PSG, okay.
Is that an exit?
Right there?
What is...
Oh, I guess there's nothing here.
Okay.
Go.
Go crawl, crawl, stay crawl!
Okay, nice.
See?
That's why the box was important, everybody.
That's why the box was so important.
Dogs just running around in circles.
Okay.
We have to go all the way back to the...
Oh my goodness.
I can't find where the door is.
I have to go all the way back to the...
To the armory?
But we will do that next time.
even though I want to keep playing.
We will do that next time.
It's rumbling in my ears again.
What is this thing?
Is that a phone?
Old.
Oh, there's stuff on the...
Oh, it's freaky.
Wait.
Oh, the mirror's all broken too.
He doesn't like to see himself.
What the heck is this thing?
I was wondering that before.
Was this in the Oh, that's the communications tower, isn't
it?
Cut.
We fight the hindee up there, right?
Oh, that's kind of funny.
Oh, fun.
Interesting.
Are those the giant staircases you climb?
Yes.
And I think we have...
Oh, yeah.
We have 14 chaff grenades.
We're doing well.
We're doing alright.
Wait, are there any...
Are we still alone in here or...
Oh.
No, we're not.
Okay.
Gonna go here.
Okay, yeah.
We're gonna go back inside.
I'm gonna save.
Oh.
Save.
Save, save.
And, um...
Yeah, we'll finish it off here.
You call it, Snake?
Yep.
Nice.
Save complete.
The Chinese say it is the strong swimmer who most often
drowns.
It's because the strong swimmer overestimates his abilities
and underestimates the strength of the river.
You're probably quite used to the mission now, but don't get
careless.
No, I'm not careless.
I'm very careful.
Do you remember what day tomorrow is?
um you know I thought about maybe if I finish this next week
maybe doing like um like playing Metal Gear Solid like
Sunday, Monday, Tuesday or I don't know I don't know how
long it would take me maybe even like Saturday, Sunday,
Monday, Tuesday of uh like the 27th, 28th, 29th 30th so
maybe because I knew the other day I was just like oh my
gosh it's April I can do April 30th So, um, the OG, of
course, I mean, well, actually, it would probably be the
Master Collection.
Uh, or, I already, I've done the, uh, the HD Collection.
Probably will be the Master Collection.
But, um, depends on how, how, I don't know, I don't know if
I would need four days.
I guess it depends on how much I play each day, right, and
how, how well I do.
I think I'll, I don't know, we might do it, who knows, but,
um,
um, the master collection kind of poopy.
No, they fixed it.
They, they have, they have done a lot of patches.
I think it's most, I think it's, I think it's like pretty
much up to speed now from what I understand.
Like they've done a lot of, a lot of patches on it, so, um,
updates are great, yeah, That was good run, Min.
Thank you!
Andrigos, thanks for the 10 gift!
I do want to keep playing, but...
I am still not sure about a stream tomorrow.
Actually, there's actually something I kind of want to play.
There was a new, um, Hollow Indie game that came out.
Like the, wow, wow, Korone...
Korone...
Box?
Hold on.
What is it called?
Korone...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow,
wow, wow, wow, because I was thinking of playing that
tomorrow, so, um, since I didn't have a game planned or
anything, um, so, I'm not sure what time yet, uh, might
start, actually, around the same time as today's stream, so,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, and, uh, but it looks really fun and
really cute, so I wanted to try it out, and I love Korone,
son, so, mm-hmm, I haven't seen it yet, so that'd be good to
see.
Yeah, yeah, I want to try it.
It looks so fine.
And yeah.
Methanar, thank you for the tan gift in.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I saw that she got a new outfit today.
It's so, it's not what I expected.
Like, it's so, it's so cool.
The Viking style It's so... I like her how messy and like
shaggy her hair is.
It's really cute.
So yeah.
It's so her too.
Yeah.
The Vinland Saga fit.
Her new song?
Oh wait.
I don't... I don't... I don't... I don't know if I heard her
new song.
I'm not gonna listen to it here, but...
Oh,
trouble with...
Wander.
That's so cute.
I will listen to it.
But yeah.
Glad we got to watch you play Twin Snakes at last.
Me too.
Oh my gosh.
The cutscenes are killing me.
Each time they're so crazy.
It's so much fun.
They're so so so fun.
Like they're so outlandish.
I love them.
For real.
Thank you, Marilyn!
Thank you for the stream.
You can never have enough MGS.
Those laughing pictures from the Mantis fight will give
you...
Those are really creepy.
I did not expect that.
I did not.
It was freaky.
It was freaky, freaky.
But, yeah.
Still so surreal seeing this game in, like, HD.
It's cool.
It is very different.
the original but I'm glad it exists me too I agree I think I
like obviously I don't say I don't say like this is a you
know a remake remake that's why I'm very interested in what
it's in what MGS 3 Delta will be like you know I don't think
it'll I mean I don't know I don't think it'll be like this
but it seems like they're remaining true to the original so
i'm very curious like if it's just gonna be the same game
but maybe hopefully with like uh better gameplay and um just
like the cut scenes all the same just hd graphics thank you
for the 50 gifted thank you thank you so much i wouldn't i
wouldn't really want it to be like this so um but we shall
see I suppose we shall see this one it does the cut scenes
do feel really weird because like the tone is just
completely different in the original like you can feel like
this cold hollow net hollowness you know like because the
audio is so like it's echoey and it's and it just feels like
so different and like so each has a different energy like
this one is so much more action and crazy outlandish but so
it's not i don't think i it's like i don't prefer this one
but i also still love this one because it's so funny yeah
way different atmosphere yeah and the music in the first one
so it just hits so good like it just even for me when i was
first playing it like
I never even seen footage of it as a kid Like I never
touched it until I first played it But like it still felt
like nostalgic There's just something about it Then I did
like Psycho Mantis's Remix That was cool But still it's
different Yeah Humma, humma, humma, humma Humma, humma,
humma Twin Snake seems pretty great so far.
It is a lot of fun.
It's, uh, I'm, I'm, uh, kind of like, oh, if I play this and
then play MGS2 next, maybe I won't, like, uh, well, the
controls will be, uh, a little different, but maybe it'll,
it'll be like more, I'll be a little bit more used to it.
Because I have not, I have not touched MGS2.
I last played it.
Twin Snake seems like Otakon retelling the story to add his
Otaku-Weep flair to the reality of what actually happened.
That's my favorite theory.
Mint Doka?
Mint Coco!
But yeah, thank you guys for hanging out with me, with
playing this, and I think I'm going to go to bed.
I was a little late.
for a stream today.
I had to delay it by about 45 minutes.
Which again, uh, actually, I don't think I apologized for
that in the beginning.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry that I was late.
I had some errands and, um, hold on.
Uh, let me, I did save, right?
I'm actually, I plan on talking just a little tiny bit more,
but I'm actually going to turn off the GameCube because, uh,
I don't want it to I'm gonna just turn it off.
Okay.
So I was a little bit late.
But I cannot say why.
I
cannot say why I was a little bit late.
Hmm.
Mysterious.
Curious.
Yes.
I had some errands.
I went out.
I went out of my maid cafe.
We did a little bit of outside haunting.
Hmm.
Taco bell.
I wish I had taco bell today.
Minty got to play Eternal Darkness.
I do want to.
Who said giving birth?
Huh?
I can't I don't think ghosts can give birth I don't I don't
I don't think ghosts
hmm no but uh Gragonant Congratulations Yeah, you'll be
saying that You'll be saying that later You will be You will
be saying that later Once I can tell you Maybe Maybe
Maybe Maybe Yeah I think so But yeah, sorry, I can't tell
you yet But I also May have hinted about it in the next
podcast episode on Monday so be sure to listen to episode
three three three three three three three yes three three
yeah so it feels so much longer when someone was just like
oh almost two weeks that you've been back but i mean maybe
if you count april first but i don't know
sorry podcast episode three snake eater cheap rig no i'm
gonna go sleep minty it was fun to be here i'm just getting
sleepy have a good night thanks for hanging out until the
end congratulations in advance.
I hope it's a healthy, big baby boss.
Boss baby!
Boss baby, boss baby!
Can't wait for April 30th.
April 30th.
I almost am just like, yeah, I can wait because I have so
much that I need to plan and think of.
But I'm like, wait, I want time to slow down a little bit.
I don't need it to go so quickly but um hopefully uh but the
brain rot i missed you like i missed that raft you belong on
you belong on this boat
man came back just to say thanks for the stream thank you
thank you thank you time either goes too fast or too slow I
know.
Sometimes, though, if it's too slow, you gotta just think
and be like, okay, you know what?
It might be something that I'm doing that I don't like.
And it's going too slow and I just want it to pass.
But at the same time, you should appreciate the slow times
too, because, um, you know, then if you're just like, when
it gets too fast, it's too, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's,
It's hard to notice.
It's hard to notice things in the moment when things are too
fast.
You know?
Like a kidney stone.
If you have a kidney stone, go on a roller coaster.
Like, I think, what is it?
Thunder Mountain third seat from the last or something?
What's your sub?
Huh?
What?
Yeah.
If you have a kidney stone, some doctors actually, I want to
say doctors.
You know what?
I'm not a doctor, so don't listen to that.
uh some things do uh i have read that that it is also said
that you should go on a on like certain roller coasters that
will help dislodge it i feel like 2024 just came but now
it's already april i know i know right well i mean i spent
two months in japan and that flew by so quickly so to me i I
can't even believe it's April.
Mid-April, I thought.
Disclaimer.
Mint is not a doctor.
No, I am a ghost maid.
I am not a doctor.
Hmm.
Yet.
With jumping out of a plane work.
No, I think you actually need like the bumpiness of a roller
coaster to dislodge it.
Like, look it up, look it up, look it up.
Sakura, I'm here to go.
Sooooo!
ZENZEN MIENAKATO!
ZANENNANO.
Well, it's okay.
Next year, there's a lot of fun.
And I've been having a lot of fun since you've been back
with...
Thank you!
Thanks, Nixie!
congratulations on being a doctor stop spoiling
stop it
I don't need excuses to go on a roller coaster all I'm
saying is that it could help if you have a kidney stone it
could help not 100% but you know
yeah yeah Hi, Asu!
Hot nursement.
What?
Tomorrow, like I said, I think I'll be streaming same
time-ish.
Not as on the schedule, but as when I started the stream.
So, about 4 p.m.
EST.
I'll make a waiting room for it tonight.
But as usual, I probably won't be streaming on Monday.
So...
so you can watch the watch the no yes listen to the podcast
listen to the podcast listen to it you guys i have a
question sorry i just opened up twitter when when did
yapping become like the word you know what i mean when did
uh like i feel like ever since i came back like every
everyone started saying like i'm doing a yapping stream When
did that happen?
Three months ago?
Two to...
So it's recent, huh?
I was like, I've never seen it before.
When I come back and suddenly everyone's like, I'm yapping.
I'm yapping here.
When the Twitch emote got popular.
Oh, it's a Twitch emote.
Oh, I heard it for the first time from Tuna.
Mint Phantom MD.
MD stands for made doctor yes I just ordered one of 5,000
key card set from MGS oh yes nice I did want to get those
two but it kind of feels weird that I like there's it feels
weird that they are three different cards yappityy up yappy
up like I've heard of yapping before is like a word like i
didn't think it was a new word but i was surprised that so
many vtubers were using it for their streams like if
sometimes for like zatsudan and stuff i would like call them
chit chatting but but now they're all becoming yapping
yapping is from tick tock oh wait who nobody oh wait the
sources are getting crossed okay hi welcome to membership mr
bones welcome to membership thank you Yeah, it just kind of
picked up.
And like, Matara says it all the time too, so I'm just like,
Yep, yep, yep.
Play Ace Combat.
Oh my gosh.
What is this username?
You don't have to super chat me to play it.
Though I don't have any plans on playing it super soon, but
you can probably see it in the future.
Dr. Mint playing as Big Boss.
I'm not big boss I'm solid mint
It's popularized on TikTok Just looked at it up There's
actual research on roller coasters and kidney stones Thunder
Mountain is recommended roller coaster That's what I said
That's what I said I don't know if you remember but one time
In Among Us you said you have a very large PP is it still
true Having a large PP is a physical not a physical is a
state it's a mindset it's a mindset right I'd say I'd say
sure Mary it's a state of mind a mindset yes the big peepee
grind set
yeah yeah just just think it and you got it april has been
great so far my kamiyoshi is back from hiatus i start a new
job my best friend got engaged here's to a fun sever oh my
gosh congrats baloney let's go the solid mint imply the
existence of liquid mint and gas mint well i mean if i'm a
ghost i'm like kind of gaseous maybe i don't want to say
that I think I don't want to say that I don't think I should
say that I don't think I should say I'm gassy I don't think
I should okay hold on hold on if I say something stupid I
gotta do this
hold on
oh wait oh no hold on hold on I messed up I messed up hold
on I messed up I messed up
thank you Thank you, soup.
If I say something dumb.
And I put this over my face.
There we go.
I should not say.
I should not say what I just said earlier.
Um.
I don't I don't Miss Miss thank you Congratulations on
threatening that accountant And getting your taxes done The
thank you Oh you can come back I mean I didn't threaten
anyone As mentioned Ryuhei did a one-to-one Cutscene remake
of the OGPS1 cutscenes Before Kojima told him specifically
Make it like one of his action films And then refilm them I
did know about that I did know about that Yes yes the really
fun stream mint i'm so happy to get to see you play it and
enjoy all the silly cutscenes i'm so happy seeing you react
to snakes sounds like a spy movie it's so goofy it really
does feel like autocad retelling it does ggg ghastly ghastly
ghost ghastly ghastly ghost
okay i have to have this on the ready wee woo wee wooe wooe
wooe
Oh, no!
Avert, avert, avert your eyes!
Don't!
Don't watch!
Don't do not watch.
Let's pick a better...
Oh no, I think, uh...
Oh, a bunch of my fonts got.
Here we go.
This one's kind of cuter.
and then let's make it center wait why is it like off like
that oh there we go okay outline a little bit more oh oh
here we go oh that's as thick as it can get oh wait hold on
if i make it this size and there i'm making this really
official aren't i oh it's a small and oh wait wait reset
reset there we go oh this one too there we go okay okay okay
now that's there we go
Okay.
Clippers be like, that sign can't stop me because I can't
read.
Okay.
Alright guys, I'm going to head out now.
Thanks again for sticking to the very end.
New Evo.
Put it on the bandana.
I'm going to head out.
thank you guys so much as always for all the support all the
gift and memberships all the super chats all the donations i
appreciate appreciate you guys so much even though it
overwhelms me in a good way though in a good way you guys
have been like so crazy supportive and awesome and i
appreciate it so much so i will see you guys later maybe
tomorrow if you want to come watch And yeah, thank you super
chat!
Thank you!
Wait, I saw it.
Where'd it go?
Wait, beep, beep.
Never mind.
Did I imagine that?
I don't know.
Can I use that incoming bad clip sound bite as my channel
intro?
Yes, of course.
Of course.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, no it's not.
I'm so confused.
Anyway.
Oh, let's bust in our way out of here.
It's busting our way out of here.
Busting our way out of here.
Yeah.
Something strange.
Sleeping in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
There's something weird.
Sleeping in your bed.
your bed.
Ow!
Let me tell you something.
Busting makes me feel good.
Busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting,
busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting,
busting.
If you're seeing things, I'm sleeping in your bed.
Thanks for the stream!
Awesome, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Bustin makes me feel good!
Thanks for the super chat!
Ow!
Let me tell you something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin,
Bustin Makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good,
feel good!
Bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin Bustin, bustin,
bustin, bustin, bustin Makes me feel good, feel good, feel
good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good,
feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, baby!
Thank you, Winane!
Let me sleep in your bed.
Shoo!
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good.
I'm afraid of no sleep.
I'm afraid of no bed.
An invisible bed.
Freaking ghost bed!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Thank you guys again for hanging out with me today and
everything I hope you guys have a great weekend I hope you
have a good rest of your weekend if I don't see you tomorrow
eat something yummy Well, it's kind of late for me, but if
it's not so late for you, get something good tonight to eat.
Whatever you want, it's the weekend, baby!
Yeah!
Makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel
good, feel good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Have a good rest of your night.
Feel good, feel good Gonna go celebrate my birthday My
birthday, my sister's birthday Happy birthday to your sister
What's up, meet y'all?
Bye-bye, thank you